Okay.
What's going on?
It's bill burr and it is time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and Ah,
just checking in on
motherfuck us.
Um,
how are you,
how was your week going?
Oh,
that's love.
Don't let it get you down,
you know?
Um,
yeah,
I'm recording this fucking Wednesday night.
I got so much shit to do tomorrow.
I didn't even realize it.
You know,
it's the usual shit,
you know?
Um,
I'm just gonna do a bunch of stuff.
I was wondering,
is there any way that you could handle the other stuff?
Oh,
it's good to have this job.
Could you do that stuff?
Okay.
Well,
you know,
I was already had some stuff.
Honey would be a big help if he could choose to do these stuff.
Do you do put the stuff that you were already going to jail?
That bullshit.
It happens.
Yeah.
Do you one of those things that happens?
Um,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know what the fuck to tell you guys.
Hey,
I'm starting a Patrion page,
by the way.
I Dunno when it's coming out,
but it's going to be all this extra shit.
Okay.
A bunch of extra shit,
a whole bunch of extra shit and uh,
you know,
I guess some helicopter videos and whatnot and some other shit.
This is sort of a pre promotional promotional thing here.
I,
you know,
if I was supposed to bring it up,
I think I was supposed to wait until I had more shit on the sat.
You know what I mean?
So it'd be worth it.
Worth it to you.
I basically just trying to become this little fucking,
you know,
you have a goal.
Yeah.
Little town.
This is sort of placed that makes little candies,
you know?
Okay.
And they just fucking,
they hang in there despite the fact across the street there's a Mcdonald's or
you know,
there's a fucking Walmart Assam Shit.
This just this fucking guy down there.
He repairs shoes,
whatever the fuck he does.
That's all I'm trying to do in this business.
She's trying to have my little fucking shop
be bringing enough fucking money on my own.
So these Steven cons out here,
you know,
I can't even tell you some of the shit that I've done.
Like I've really,
like a long time ago I saw this documentary and this fucking musician said you
are better to own something 100% and sell 20,000 copies then did not own it at
all and sell 20 million.
You're actually going to make more if you just sell 20,000 if it's your own,
if you own it.
And it's one of the truest fuck it things
I've ever,
ever heard other than
okay,
don't stay friends with your ex girlfriend.
You know,
you break up with a girl,
you gotta get the fuck away from her.
Cause uh,
you know,
it's just,
it's,
you know what,
don't listen to me generally speak.
Some of them are cool,
some of them get it,
some are happy for you.
The rest of them,
Jay,
you got to get away from him.
You know what I mean?
It's like when there's mold in the house,
so you got to go,
you're going to die.
Okay.
Does that make sense?
Do I need to sing a song about it?
I don't know what the fuck to tell you.
All I know is that I am sitting here alone in this God damn rum and my fucking
chest hurts.
I think I have a bruised sternum.
This fucking guy,
like the end of last year,
he was trying to show me what the fuck happened on this football play and I as
he was coming towards me,
I should have been like,
dude,
I saw it.
I saw the play and he went to pick me up and he fucking compacted my fucking
ribs and I think it fucked up my sternum.
Either that or I have to,
I dunno what it is,
but you know I'm going to go see a doctor about it.
See what the deal is now that I've fucking been here for like a,
why does this fucking couch scratch ups?
Do they make anything nice anymore?
But these fucking leather couches,
you stick anything on it?
Everything gets all fucked.
That fucking hacked up.
Look at this shit.
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
it gives a fuck.
Right?
I guess that adds character,
but it looks like a bunch of hack marks on it
anyways.
Um,
college football starts this weekend,
Dat,
Dat da rock song
by Blah,
blah,
blah.
Papa,
Papa.
But they're all the same fucking song.
But
B,
you know,
people have some sort of hand gesture that they fucking throw up,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
anyways,
Mike,
most beginnings of most college football seasons,
there's not a lot of good games.
Okay.
So the ones you want to look out here,
speaking of,
of,
of his University of Michigan,
Yay.
I'll to the,
there is val yet right against our Notre Dame.
He was and a fucking ass.
Oh he was dying and he said where in one for far kid me,
cause I'm a selfish comment and I'm still thinking about me.
I don't even know if that even happened when one for the gipper was that
Hollywood adding a dialog,
some shit that was never said,
you know,
like you complete me.
MMM.
Anyways,
now the good ones is a Lsu first Miami.
That could be a decent one.
Just as far as ranked teams,
actually each other.
Other than that,
Virginia Tech,
Florida State 20 Verse 19 I love it.
How the fuck did they do the rankings at the,
so many people leave.
How do they figure out who's what?
You know you can watch number for Wisconsin against Western Kentucky.
We think the spread is on that look at Tcu is not ranked against southern you
Komal frogs.
What happened?
I don't know why I fucking,
I know why.
Because they came to the rose bowl that one time and everybody was dressed like
a fucking douche bag.
Everybody,
all of eating,
all the guys were all dressed like jr Ewing.
You know that this like dress and classy.
Right?
And then there's just like you just a privileged can't and it's neither one of
those is probably true.
Well actually dressing classes too.
But the second part,
they probably won't even privilege cons.
I probably just looked at them and just judge the shit out of them.
There's probably what really happened.
I bet there's nothing wrong with tacy.
You come all frogs?
MMM.
I Dunno what they just,
they just,
they just look like assholes.
Not the women.
Just the guys sit there.
You know what I mean?
He's sitting there,
this stupid fucking loafers and a fucking blue blazer.
Who wears that to a football game?
Right?
Why are you dressed like an usher?
I Dunno.
It's amazing how long ago I saw that in the fact that it's still bugs me.
It doesn't bug me as much as how easily these chairs fucking scratch evidently.
Oh,
well
what are you going to do?
You know what I mean?
You know what's funny is I got these chairs,
not for a lot of money because they're like,
hey,
here's some vintage fucking chairs,
right?
So you know what these old ass fuck first one is zillion dollars for these
vintage leather chairs,
right?
So I've got just buy some new ones and I'll put the fucking hack mark cinema.
Now every hack mark that's getting goes in it.
Now my,
what happened,
Bill,
was exactly what you said you wanted in your couches,
and now that's happening and now you're upset about,
all right,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
How about those?
Red Sox,
ah,
born and on the offense,
the bats,
the bats hanging in there,
hanging in there while I pitching staff all goes on the fucking DL.
Chris sale once again is on the 10 day disabled list.
David Price got hit by a line drive.
Oh,
come back or write to the mound,
the x rays when negative,
but they're going to take more fucking,
more x rays,
you know,
so we shall see.
That's why my ESPN,
oh,
it's all over.
Or beginning of August.
You never know what can happen with all the fucking injuries.
Um,
so anyways,
I was watching that.
Uh,
yeah,
I'll tell you what my daughter does.
You know,
it's fucking hilarious.
Did I tell you she imitates the old old man noises I make when I pick her up.
I right.
Come on sweetie,
let's go.
And I pick up,
uh,
she looks at me and she goes,
ah,
I don't know.
I,
maybe I already told you that story.
I'm old.
I don't remember.
Speaking of all that went to the gym today and after bragging about my perfect
form,
I somehow threw out my back trying to make sure I was doing the middle of my
back check PZ exercises.
So my fucking chest and shoulders wouldn't pull my fucking know.
My chess wouldn't pull my shoulders forward against,
I wouldn't fuck up my rotator cuffs,
my rotator cuffs,
doing great.
Then I end up fucking up my back.
I can't,
when I think I'm at that age where I got it,
Nah,
I just gotta I gotta you know,
somebody finally said,
I said,
why don't you get a fucking personal trainer and just have him go over there?
All the exercises you're going to do.
They'll put together a workout plan that tell you how to do the,
the,
the exercise correctly.
And I've always said,
Nah,
fuck that.
Fuck that.
I know what I'm doing.
You know,
Because in the eighties I went,
I went over to a friend's house and he's going to,
come on,
let's work out,
make a friend of mine just gave you a bench.
Do this.
Nothing about grip,
nothing about form,
nothing.
Do some curls.
This is good for you.
Didn't fucking know.
And then you'd go to the den,
you joined a gym,
right?
You joined Gold's or world gym or whatever the fuck it was right back in the
day.
And then you just see somebody doing an exercise,
you know,
they seemed approachable.
You'd be like,
Hey,
what's that?
What does that do?
And if they seemed intimidating,
you just sort of watch it out of the corner of your eye and then you just start
doing it.
He had no idea what you were doing,
what the fuck it was working.
You would basically guess what it was doing,
and then you didn't work the opposite muscle and you fucked yourself up.
It had I just gone out and got a personal trainer from day one.
If they even fucking existed back in the 80s,
I don't think they did.
You just went to the gym.
Um,
I wouldn't have all of these problems today.
So there you go.
There you go.
Everybody.
You learn how to play drums,
wear earplugs from day one.
If you're going to go to the gym,
get a fucking trainer from day one,
learn what the fuck the correct way to do shit.
So you don't end up like me,
end up hurting yourself trying to fix something else.
My fucking shoulder is doing great.
Yeah.
There's nothing worse than thrown out the top of your back.
I don't know what it is.
Lower back up,
just so used to that pain.
It's like acceptable to toppy it back.
It's fucking,
and I explain it takes your breath away.
So I've been dealing with that off all day,
you know what I mean?
And my Kiddo,
you know,
she likes getting picked up all the time.
So I was making extra old band android,
uh,
anyways,
but it's still worth it.
That pain for a kid is the best.
No worries.
You know,
I'll take that day of the week.
The kids are fucking right.
She's got a great sense of humor and she likes to rough house.
It's,
it's perfect.
It's perfect.
You know.
Oh,
she loves vamp arena,
man.
I got to,
I'm getting sick of that show,
you know?
Yeah.
The fucking little blue chick.
She's always having problems fitting in.
I get it.
She's different.
Every fucking God damn episode.
And then the other two people have to fucking help her out.
You know what she reminds me of?
She reminds me of an addict.
You know where it's always about them and you've got to fail.
No,
no,
you're doing great.
What's the matter?
What's the matter now?
You know,
I don't really mind it.
Fancy.
Nancy's the one I don't like that one fucking chicken all.
She's,
she's just sitting there and you all she's about as material thinks.
She always tried to have the nicest shit.
She somehow gets status and then give friends or whatever is like,
what the fuck are we watch?
I don't want to watch this shit.
You know?
So instead I was watching a little bit of the red sox with my daughter before
she went to bed.
And then,
um,
okay.
Afterwards,
uh,
you know,
it's funny actually nodded off when I was watching vampire arena.
And you have like that panic when you fall asleep,
like three seconds that you kids like walking up to an alligator or some shit.
And I just opened my eyes and she was just looking right at me and she,
and I opened my eyes.
She just looks at me and she just goes,
hi,
what's up buddy?
Sorry.
Oh,
fucking old freckles nodded off too.
So anyways,
I put her to bed and I went on Instagram and I saw Joe Rogan was promoting a,
or just talking about,
oh,
we just watched this documentary about Leonard Skinner.
Okay,
sorry for the Onyx.
I was like,
God,
I gotta check this shit out.
And I just watched it on showtime.
It's called,
if I leave here tomorrow,
um,
and I gotta tell you,
man,
these fucking old southern guys that is still around.
I mean,
I literally had to put on the,
the,
uh,
the closed caption so I can understand what the fuck they were saying.
And Jesus Christ,
incredible documentary.
But it's also amazing at how similar,
you know,
so many of these bands stories are,
and it's just because they get into that,
they get into the music business where they getting fucking ripped off and they
just put them on the wheel and the business just gives a shit about money and
they don't give a fuck if they run a band into the fucking ground because
there's always another band that they can sign.
And plus who,
why would you want to rep an old band?
They know all the tricks and how you're going to try to steal from them.
They'll probably try to get the rights to their music back,
so fuck up,
you know,
then he locked,
they'll blame each other and break up and then we'll move on to the next band.
Like that's literally how the music fucking business worked.
Um,
so I'm sitting there watching this shit and um,
just,
you know,
that whole,
just the work ethic and just keeping it simple in the beginning and then they
just get stuck in the,
uh,
the craziness of touring.
I don't want to ruin any of it,
but definitely,
uh,
definitely check it out.
And just also how great the band sounds in the night.
Just seeing people singing live and playing live with other human beings is
incredible.
I don't know,
man.
I'm kind of going off the rails here,
dude.
I'm just,
I can't remember the last time I watched something from this century,
by the way.
I've been watching that Peter Gunn on me TV bed at eight.
Dude,
dude,
it,
that's where that song came from,
right?
That is the worst lit show in the history of anything that was ever fucking lit.
At first.
I thought it was like a style thing.
Like for you,
if you guys don't eat the business here,
like when they go to light a scene,
I never understood why this shadow was like a big full gives a fuck up.
There's a shadow.
Right?
But it's just like if you know,
if you're in a room,
okay,
like if,
I don't know,
I don't even know how to explain this cause this,
this is really beyond my ability.
All I know is that's what's so fucked up is they'll be in a dimly lit room and
one person's talking and then this is a shadow behind him and then somebody
right behind them,
like wrecked directly cross talk for them.
So if anything,
the shadow,
that person should be on the person talking,
but one of them they turn around to go to that person.
Then that person has a shadow behind them.
They literally had like one light and they just would stick it in front of
people.
So this episode ends
okay.
I'm not saying it's a bad show,
it's just a badly,
poorly lit lit show.
This woman standing there and because she's standing in like,
uh,
the opening to this apartment building where it,
okay.
It's not straight on the walls.
They sorta angle in towards the door.
Her shadow was on both sides.
Yeah.
When she's standing there and don't just saying,
okay,
maybe that's how they lit the building in which she standing.
All right.
Then she walks,
it's the end of the episode.
She goes down the street.
Now we're behind her and as she's walking away,
as the camera rises up,
you literally see the shadow of the camera and the fucking guy,
the guy's head and body hanging off the side off going off the building in the
background that she's walking towards.
And it's like,
how the fuck did somebody missed that?
So,
um,
but you got to watch Peter Gunn.
All right?
It's on me TV.
I still highly recommend it.
It's fucking hilarious.
You,
you will never see a character die faster.
Okay?
They only had fucking 22 minutes to have somebody get killed,
to have Peter Gunn to try to figure out with what the fuck happened to have
Peter get the living shit kicked out of him.
And then for him to solve the fucking murder,
they had to do all of that in 22 fucking minutes.
So it always just starts.
One of them started there like,
ladies and gentlemen on piano,
please welcome 88 keys.
Ketty whatever the fuck his name is.
And the curtain comes up.
And the guy's just sitting there with this weird look on his face.
And then he just keels over with a knife in his back and then it just goes
banner.
No,
no,
no.
Why?
Okay,
so another one,
a guy gets on a fucking elevator and the elevator stops.
He's pushing the button and he's like,
what the fuck's going on?
And all of a sudden the trapdoor above it opens up in a gun with a silencer,
comes through.
Fucking guy drops down,
debt goes down to the first floor,
opens up,
the guy reacts to the dead body.
They,
that was it.
Then they're right in there.
And I gotta Tell You,
Peter Gunn is sort of the precursor to that.
David Duchovny minimalist style of acting.
MMM.
Guy Crushes it.
Okay.
And then also 77 sunset strip,
they would do foreshadowing to the middle of the episode like you saw at the
beginning of Goodfellas and a lot of Martin Scorsese movies,
everybody always,
I always think,
oh,
they're ripping off Martin Scorsese.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
77 sunset strip did this shit.
Maybe he watched a few episodes.
I don't know.
This is Lucy.
We see what this podcast is becoming.
This is becoming an old fucking man.
I got to,
what are you guys watching that's worth watching?
Okay,
I don't know what it is cause my wife dominates the TV.
I love it at death.
What am I going to say?
No.
And she's literally sitting there,
she's watching that Andy Cohen show where all the,
the little old ladies get together with their fucking 20 pounds of makeup and
they just start fucking saying mean shit to each other.
I liked one of them.
One of them was a drunk,
clearly was a drunk and they would tell on her that she needed to go into Rehab.
She goes,
I don't need to go in and Rehab.
And I'd probably say now went into Rehab was was my cousin and that was because
you know they,
you know,
she didn't,
she go to jail was saying like that's why you go to Rehab.
And they were like,
yes,
but sometimes you have to go to rehab because you have a problem.
Well I don't have a prominent guy.
Yeah,
I'm not going to prop.
That's what she does.
She,
she did the fucking
Archie bunker like fuck you guys.
And you could just hear in her voice,
even if she wasn't drunk,
just like she,
she's at that level of booze with a bottle has like a fucking handle.
You know,
it's like a jug.
You buying that cheap shit with like a carton of cigarettes.
There is something to be said.
Okay.
For going out like that,
you know,
to just give in to all of it.
Sugar,
salt,
liquor,
fucking smoke.
I Dunno.
I think it's all good right up until you get sick and then you die.
Then you're like,
ah,
you know,
I could have been fucking,
I should have jogged an eight apricots,
you know,
Dan,
what
I mean if it really is just a blink of the eye.
Yeah.
Well you know,
as far as how long the universe has been here,
oh Geez.
I'm going deep now.
Right.
Deep.
For me anyways,
if it really is a blink of the eye,
just the amount of time that human beings have walked the earth,
you know,
who gives a fuck
if you live to be 30 Oh fucking a hundred right.
Well,
you know,
it gives a fuck the,
I guess the person
cause for you,
that's a long fucking time or really short time,
right.
Not Saying,
you know,
I wouldn't give a fuck if I was dying.
I'm just saying,
you know what I mean?
You know,
I'm really saying is that I've been eating like an angel and I barely been
drinking and uh,
trying to get my abs back here.
And uh,
this is one of these nights where,
uh,
you know,
I dunno,
it's kind of nodding at me
where I used to drink booze,
like my late night snack now is,
is heirloom tomatoes.
I just cut a few of them up and I actually fucking look forward to it.
I liked drinking smoothies in the morning.
I fucking love that for breakfast with Kale and spinach,
bananas and fucking Chia seeds and all of that shit.
But every fucking once in a while,
you know,
well,
everybody once in a while I've kind of mean like every night.
This week I just feel like,
just like fuck,
you know,
so
I don't know.
What do you do about that?
You know,
I just go,
I'm just not going to do it right now.
I'll go do a fucking podcast.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck that means.
Pride.
It means I have issues.
Right.
Okay.
It's weird because I haven't eaten any fucking,
I haven't eaten any fucking ice cream cookies,
any of that fucking shit.
And I'm not thinking about any of that at all.
But booze is the one that always,
it always comes back knocking,
you know?
Yeah.
Like didn't Elizabeth Elizabeth Taylor married like the same guy like twice.
We always say these fuck when I want with the fucking record is for that.
Most Times two people got married.
Okay.
Most Times two people
got remarried.
What's going on in the world by the way of
what happened this week?
Tennessee couple gets married a record a hundred times.
Nine Times.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I don't want to hear that.
That's bullshit.
World Records for marriages and divorces after knocking for 21 how many people
in America get remarried?
Yeah,
she get towel once.
Woman tied the knot 23 fucking times.
Yeah.
Jesus tries talking about a codependent psychopath to key.
You can't fucking be alone.
Grandmother is most married woman after tying the knot 23 times cheese can
imagine the fucking check she was collected.
Well,
actually no,
that's not true,
right?
Because once you're married,
the next person,
okay,
Jesus Christ.
How?
How easy would it be to fucking divorce her?
I'll make payments for eight months.
She'll fucking find somebody else getting married again.
American grandmother,
Linda Wolf has become the most married woman in the world.
I'm surprised she's not a great grandmother.
All that cock going into her,
Huh?
After walking down the aisle 23 times and is now on the lookout for number 24.
Mrs. Wolf 68.
Okay.
Is included in the Guinness Book of World Records for the dubious honor of being
wed more times than anyone else alive Jew.
She must be the first time and be like,
Hey,
could you not put your shoes here?
I,
you know what,
go fuck yourself.
Amati so over
Linda,
uh,
she has said she is addicted to romance to the romance of getting married.
Oh,
she likes it in the beginning.
Born Linda Lou Taylor,
the American or the American first marriage in 1957 at the age six date to a 31
year old called George Scott,
former first baseman of the Boston red sox.
I'm the union lasted for seven years,
the longest and happiest if any of her marriages since then,
things have tended to go downhill.
Okay.
Oh,
that's funny.
She got divorced at 23 for the first time when she went on to marry 23 times.
I'm over the subsequent decades.
She'd married a one eyed convict,
a preacher,
a bar,
man.
It sounds like an Irish song.
They're green alligators and the one eyed conduct.
A fucking preacher and a bar man and a plumber and musicians,
plural.
Oh Jesus.
Two turned out to be homosexuals too.
Are homeless at one beat her.
I mean,
that's pretty good,
man.
You only got beat.
You get married 23 times.
You only get beat once a minute.
It's pretty good.
You forget somebody's got married 23 times.
They just had bad choices in men.
Another put a padlock on her fridge.
Oh,
there's a guy that's called marrying for looks
getting fat.
They are hunting.
I swear to God you have another fucking best get.
I'm putting a padlock on that fucking fridge.
Watch me,
watch me.
And then he fucking does it.
And then she have to go fuck yourself.
I'm Outta here.
Who's too controlling?
He was counting the level,
the amount of pop tarts I was eating.
Um,
okay.
One marriage lasted just 36 hours because the love just wasn't there.
But Linda from Indiana once married the same man,
check girly three times.
She's had seven children by or different husbands and has been a stepmother to
many more.
Her last marriage a decade ago was a publicity stunt.
It was to,
yeah.
Glenn Wolf,
who and taking Linda as his bride meant he was the world's most married man at
29 times,
29 times on Jesus.
He died a year later at 88
hmm.
I bet.
God's first fucking statement to him is,
what the fuck were you?
Fuck are you doing?
What was that?
Were you an asshole
after 17 times?
Did you really think the last 12 times are going to be different?
Your fucking moron.
No sense sending you to hell buddy.
You've already been there.
Come on in.
Alright.
Consequently,
consequently she said she was,
that she was on the lookout for number 24 she told the son,
it's been years since I walked down the aisle.
I miss it.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
She's like fucking,
she's like an athlete that doesn't know how to retire.
The serial bride who now lives in a retirement home,
said she had never cheated on a husband you didn't have fucking time to.
She said if she had her life over again,
she would never ever marry so many men.
Okay,
let it ended.
Kind of sad,
right?
So of course,
this is all of these clickbait sites.
What should every architect demand from a cloud?
Okay?
The most dangerous species alive,
Donald Trump in his younger days.
Okay.
This mom never fed her daughter carbs.
Which one do you guys want here?
This is like jeopardy for dumb people.
Volkswagen CC test.
Wild old age.
Stop us seeing,
oh,
wild will.
My eyes are going here.
We'll old age.
Stop us seeing our grandkids.
60 candid photos from the past.
A coolest new cars.
Final moments they never expected.
Oh,
he got to go with that.
click bait it.
We go.
This isn't news.
This is a new segment is a new segment called clickbait.
All right.
This is the last known picture of the RMS RMS titanic on the surface of the
ocean.
Yeah,
cause we found the fucker was taken during her maiden voyage,
had crosshaven Ireland
just after the vessel departed Queenstown where it stopped before heading
westward towards New York.
Three days after this photo was taking 1,514 would be dead and the titanic would
beat titanic would be at the bottom of the North Atlantic after colliding with
an iceberg and one of the deadliest peacetime maritime disasters in history.
Okay.
How the fuck did you hit one of those goddamn things?
I guess it was nighttime.
I didn't have the lights on.
You know,
sometimes you're driving down the street.
You had no idea.
Okay,
next page.
Okay.
And they got three advertising.
It's in there.
Fur Jacket.
Fucking microchip.
Alright.
Andrew Mccauley,
2007 well,
this doesn't look good.
This is the last known photo of Andrew Mccauley and Australian sea actor who is
now presumed dead Mccauley attempted to Kayak 994 miles across the Tasman sea in
February,
2007 was never found.
And how the fuck did they get that picture?
Okay.
Is that between,
uh,
okay.
Where's The Tasman?
Is that between Tasmania and Australia?
Yeah.
Fuck all the Australians that are acting like I'm dumb right now.
Okay.
You're at the bottom of the fucking world.
I don't know.
I don't know what goes on down there.
Taz,
man.
See maybe,
I guess correctly the Tasman Sea.
The Tasman Sea.
Yeah.
Oh,
is he trying to get all the way over to New Zealand?
Jesus Christ in a fucking boat that's like designed to tip over.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know.
Okay.
All right.
Well he definitely was trying to protect his skin.
Freddie Mercury,
1991 oh Jesus.
Yeah.
Looks like an old peewee Herman for any mercury was the lead singer of Queens.
He died of complications of age related to AIDS.
He was key confirmed the day before he died that he had contracted the disease.
This is the last known photo.
All right.
Why the fuck would I want to see that?
That's an arguably the greatest front man of all time.
Amelia.
Yeah.
45 days before she embarked on an infamous flight that would render her both
missing and eternally famous Amelia Earhart pose for a photo shoot here.
She's seen standing in front of the model 10 electra there would carry her to
her mysterious destiny.
Korean airlines flight.
Okay.
Triple o seven 1983
it's plane took off from New York because it was shut down his Soviet airspace
out Jesus Christ.
This is just getting worse.
The Ara sand,
what?
This will be a bunch of people taking selfies on bridges.
Steve Irwin,
another Australian.
Okay.
The USS Maine.
okay.
What did it fucking collide with Paul Revere.
This is the wreckage of the American battleship Maine,
which was destroyed along with 260 members of the vote,
Blah Blah likely by a mine.
They had mines even back then.
Yeah.
Fucking lit,
lit a bale of Hay on fire,
sent it out there and take out a wooden ship.
Right.
Okay.
All right.
Uh,
this is this too creepy.
Let's,
let's lighten it up with,
uh,
last selfies
before death.
Half of these effect,
by the way.
There you go.
19 selfies taking moments before disaster.
There's one with the fucking shark coming up.
10 selfies.
Yeah,
these are all fucking bullshit.
I like these things.
I want images sell.
Come on.
Couple people up on climbing up on buildings.
Oh.
Then there's the two beautiful girls in the fucking car.
Oh,
Jesus.
There's a lot of them up.
These fucking kids that like the free climbers,
they climb up the top of buildings.
There's a lot of bullshit ones at guys in pools with bad pictures of great white
sharks.
All right.
What am I doing here?
Talking a lot about death here.
Huh?
Um,
anyways,
let's get back.
Let's talk about,
uh,
I don't know what the fuck else to talk about.
If I had done a fucking half hour at this point.
You know,
I think every once in a while you should have,
oh shit.
34 minutes,
34 minutes of,
I don't know what the fuck that was.
Sorry guys.
I had to,
I had to get this thing done because I got all this other bullshit I have to end
up doing when tomorrow.
You know,
I,
I would like to think that the woman getting married nine Zillion fucking times.
Maybe there was a little bit of humor in there.
I have no idea.
I'm sorry.
Did the fucking news.
Nowadays it's just too goddamn depressing.
I just,
I don't know how you guys do it.
How do you stay informed?
Oh,
congratulations to Dean del Rey.
Everybody who got his first,
first Conan O'brien went over there for the taping.
He fucking killed it.
It was broke.
It was Mark Marin who fucking ripped on guitar.
He got to find that clip after he killed it on the couch.
He then went over and Jan with the band and fucking play guitar at a whole other
level,
um,
Dene.
Bert Kreischer killed it.
And then Dean del Ray was fucking unbelievable.
A former officer,
Roy Oliver,
sentenced to 15 years and fatal shooting of teen.
Holy Shit.
A cop went to jail.
You don't see that often,
do you?
Okay.
Code of silence,
the Blue Code.
All right.
What happened here?
A former Texas police officer role in,
in Texas.
Roy Oliver was sent us to 15 years in prison on Wednesday for the birder of
murder of a 15 year old boy who was shot while riding in a car full of teens
leaving a house party.
Uh,
all of our 38 was convicted on Tuesday in the fatal of the high school.
Fresh
freshmen,
Jordan Edwards.
All right,
hang on one second.
Let me see something.
Jordan Edwards.
Dean shot.
Oh,
I thought it was gonna be a white kid.
So they actually sent a cop to jail for fucking killing a black kid.
Oh,
there you go.
Miracles never cease.
Not shitting on the cops.
I'm just saying,
you know,
there's bad comedians.
There's bad cops,
you know.
Um,
anyways,
oh Jesus.
They probably just got myself.
I just,
why we just got myself a ticket right then and there.
I swear to God,
I'll tell you right now,
that bald,
fractured motherfucker
drives a half fucking mile over the speed limit in my county.
How dare he suggest that?
Uh,
even though human beings are flawed,
that maybe some of them are in my own.
Why am I picking on southern people there?
I don't know cause I'm limited.
Um,
all right,
I'm going to read some advertising here.
Whenever the fuck I get it,
I'll probably read it tomorrow morning.
Um,
if I'm only here to Maru,
um,
that's another thing too.
I watch all these old shows on me TV and everybody's drinking and smoking and
then I'm watching this whole thing on Leonard Skinner and everybody's drinking
smoke or do it.
Oh,
this fucking shit.
And uh,
yeah,
it starts giving you ideas.
Maybe if I got to start watching a workout shows,
maybe I should do that.
Are their workout shows whatever happened to the biggest loser?
You know,
what happened is the fucking guy on there had a goddamn heart attack figure that
one out.
And the other woman,
I don't know where she went,
she broke off.
She went solo and she started doing her own exercise videos,
if I remember correctly.
All right.
I want to read some advertising here for Y'all.
Just get a read couple advertisements here for Y'all and then I'm going to a,
you're going to listen to some music and then we're going to play a some
greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon podcast from,
I dunno,
some fucking,
I dunno when earlier this year,
maybe last year,
two years ago.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
but uh,
I'll have more information on our,
uh,
the Patriot page.
Got a bunch of things that are about all things,
comedy coming up,
a bunch of things that I would love to announce now that I'm not allowed to
announce due to contractual agreements.
And uh,
some F is for family shit.
I got all his shit coming up.
I know when it's coming out.
The ink isn't dry yet,
so I can't fucking announce it.
I really want to tell you oneF is for families coming out,
but I'm not allowed to do so yet.
I would like to,
uh,
tell you about some,
other shit we got going on,
but I'm not allowed to.
All right,
I'm talking in circles.
Here's the advertising at a,
have a great weekend.
You can't send,
I'll see you on Monday.
I'll be in there in a minute.
Okay.
Uh,
alright,
borrow.
Go ahead.
You can get out.
You can get on.
I'll just sit here.
Uh,
owning a couch from hell is like a rite
of passage.
I eat too expensive,
too heavy,
too cheap to Warren.
I'm going to get out so don't die without the park.
And they see,
oh,
you've got to pull it from the curb.
I just destroyed your door.
Um,
please use one of your negative couch experiences.
Ice Live with Bobby Kelly and he used to fight fucking find them on the sidewalk
in New York City.
So I had no idea what sort of crack head slapped and fucked on the thing.
But then after you had a bowl of cereal on it,
somehow it was yours.
Was that personal enough?
After all these years of suffering,
you owe it to yourself to experience the comfort and quality of borough.
Couch.
Borough brings style and comfort to a whole new level and ships to your door
fast and free.
Your relationship with your couch will never be the same.
Borough selfers are arrogant,
comically designed so I'm comfortable while I dunno.
Watch 77 sunset strip.
Um,
customize your birth so for software to match your style by selecting the
colors,
size,
armrest,
height and leg color.
A shipping is fast and free.
Unlike the rest of the furniture industry.
I can attest to that.
Those fucking slow bastards.
And did I mentioned it has a built in USB charger in your couch.
That's amazing and joy.
30 days of cozy on your comfortable borough risk-free or try out borough at one
of their partners SRO rooms today.
Customize your own borough and get $75 off your order by going to
borrow.com/burr B u r r a that's borough.com B u r r o w slash bar.com for $75
off your purchase borough makes the luxury couch for real life.
And lastly,
but certainly not leastly oh butcher box.
And I love these guys.
Butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass fed,
grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken,
chicken and the game changer.
Heritage bread,
pork,
the best pork chop I've ever made it home.
It's incredible and incredible quality of butcher box meat starts with a
commitment to raising animals humanely and free of antibiotics and hormones
before they kill them.
Each box comes with at least nine to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual sizes,
size,
meals,
or a couple of lunches for a fat fuck.
You can choose five different boxes.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork,
mixed box and custom box.
Let's use the custom box,
let you choose your own cuts.
Um,
uh,
in order to receive free bacon for life of subscription plus $10 off your order,
go to butcher box.com.
Click on the big bacon banner on the homepage and use the bur bur are at
checkout.
Go now.
Limited time offer.
Um,
it's the best pork chop I ever had.
Definitely recommend the heritage bread,
pork.
I'm sure the chicken and beef are great too,
but I'm loving the pork.
Alright,
there you go.
Oh,
look who's back.
Just in time for football season,
draft kings,
everybody.
Football's about to make its long anticipated return to the living rooms all
across America.
That means bragging rights and cast prices are up for grabs.
A draft,
kings.com,
the leader in one week fantasy sports with one week fantasy,
a draft kings.
You choose when to play.
Draft a new team every week with no season long commitment.
At draftkings you are the GM.
Just choose your players.
Stay under the salary cap and see how your team stacks up against the
competition.
No matter what your skill level is,
there's a contest winning,
fewer drafting.
So if you've been thinking about trying one week fantasy football,
now is the time to play because nothing makes football Sunday more exciting.
Then when you have a draft kings line up on the line to celebrate.
Week one draft king is hosting a free teen,
picked him promo,
download the APP and go to draft kings dotcom now and use Promo Code
[inaudible].
All you have to do is pick at least half of the winning teams correctly and
you'll win a share of 1 million bucks.
That's cold.
Berbee you are our only a draft kings.
The game inside the game.
Eligibility restrictions apply.
See draftkings.com/pick them for details.
All right,
this is not a bomb test or anything.
I'm doing the reads in the car here.
I am not driving,
I'm being safe.
All right,
hymns,
everybody.
Sexual performance issues more common than you think.
Uh,
your 25% over 25% of new ed cases are guys under 40 40% of men by the age of 40.
Struggle from not being able to get and maintain an erection.
Even the world's greatest actor can't fake one.
Why did it guys turned to weird solutions that do nothing when they could turn
instead to medicine and science or layoff.
Internet porn for a couple of weeks
for hims.com a one stop shop for hair loss.
Skincare,
sexual wellness from men.
Jesus,
thanks to science ed can be optional.
No waiting room,
no awkward in personal doctor visits.
So what's wrong with you?
Schmuck.
Schmaegle no lines save hours by going to four hymns.com.
Hymns connects with you with real doctors and medical grade solutions to treat
Ed.
Products are shipped directly to your door with ED products stamped on the side
of the box.
Kidding well known generic equivalents to name brand prescription to help you
combat Ed.
Try Hymns for a month today for just five bucks will get you started for just
five bucks while supplies last.
See website for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you went to the doctor or a pharmacy.
Go to himss.com h I m s.com/b U R R,
capital e d.
That's for hymns.com for h I m s.com/burr ed.
Uh,
for hymns.com/bar e d.
All right,
the next one.
What do we got here?
Who's up next?
Oh,
honey.
Millions of people are using honey to save money shopping online.
And why wouldn't they?
It's free.
Takes two,
just two clicks to add to your browser and saves you tons of money.
It's ingenious,
but one of my absolute favorite things about honey is how much better it makes
shopping on Amazon.
Um,
yeah.
Turn right here.
Uh,
please personalize this to make it your own.
I am making it my own honey magically adds all sorts of useful information right
on your Amazon page of whatever you're looking for.
Just shop like you normally do.
Honey automatically searches the 2 million sellers on Amazon to find you the
lowest price.
It even shows you the item's prices,
uh,
changes.
So you can decide if you want to buy or wait for the price to come down.
If you decide to wait,
just add it to your honey drop list and it'll notify you if the price drops.
One honey guts when honeys got your back.
You'll never overpay for anything on Amazon again.
What's the last purchase you made with honey on Amazon?
How much did it save you?
I haven't used it yet,
but I'm sure it's great.
Was that personal enough?
There's no reason to add honey to your browser today.
It's free.
Uh,
just takes two clicks to install.
We'll make sure you always get the lowest price on Amazon.
Add honey to your browser for free right now@jointhoney.com slash bird that's
join honey.com/burr
like a
boss.
We ended up watching something on TV,
one of the sickest stories ever.
And we're like,
dude,
this has to be a fucking movie.
The mega star who was Benjamin button,
that money balls,
Billy Bean is now interested in playing none other than Jimmy Keane.
And uh,
of course in the end they,
they,
they said that they were gonna turn into a movie was basically about this guy,
right?
It was this fucking show about serial killers.
So of course we're going to watch it.
In 1993,
Jesse was a high school sophomore devoted to home and family.
Jessia was really very much of a home body.
So one bike ride up the road and back she was done.
So we'll watching this thing about fucking serial killers and the whole time
that talking about this drug dealer kid,
well I kind of fucked as this and they keep showing this serial killer guy.
It's like does in the show in the drug dealer,
older,
you know,
and not in jail and all that shit going,
what the fuck happened?
You know,
just the way they put it together,
you was,
you riveting.
You know,
like what the fuck is going on here?
So basically what happened was there was this kid,
right,
he played football,
they call them the assassin because every game he ever played,
he took somebody out,
right.
Was it the assassin?
Are they called you the assassin in football?
That was a good thing.
I take it.
Yes.
Was that Jack Tatum?
Check Tatum.
Now I forget what it was.
Something like assassin.
So
he fucking,
uh,
and just movie star good looks.
All right.
And he's The star of the football team.
All the women loved him.
I mean,
this guy was just like,
he,
he looked like a movie star in his life was a movie.
So he's Big Achilles heel was,
he didn't have money and he wanted to keep up with the rich kids.
So we started dealing drugs and he ended up being really good at it.
And by the time he was like 20 years old,
this fucking guy was making like $1 million a year
expanded to cocaine.
And at the tender age of 17,
he moved to Chicago where the business and profits exploded.
He was now a big fish in a bigger pond,
Lake Michigan to be exact.
He was his own in-crowd fast cars,
faster women and souped up living
all the hot spots,
all the big nightclubs,
all the owners I was in tight with.
Um,
I would come in there and have carte blanche and every place that I went to
where you feeling invincible?
Yeah,
there was a certain point where I would say there was an invincible feeling
in almost seemed like this American greed type story as opposed to this serial
killer thing.
And they keep going back to this serial killer fucking piece of shit.
Who's killing these girls?
These teenage girls.
So long story short,
he's laying in bed one night and he's just thinking,
I got to get out of this life.
I'm so sick of looking over my shoulder.
I can't do this anymore.
How am I going to get out of his?
But he's addicted to the money.
He's addicted to the life and all of that type of stuff.
And he has this rattling on the door and I'm thinking,
oh fuck,
it's the serial killer.
And he obviously fought the guy in one.
What the fuck happens,
right?
All of a sudden the door fucking
boom,
the whole door just blew off the hinges and come flying into the house.
And all of these DEA,
FBI and locals all came in and single file line with their automatic weapons.
Yeah.
Was that alcohol,
tobacco farm?
And I don't know what the fuck it is.
So anyways,
they fucking come.
FDA Food,
Drug Administration,
the uh,
transit Chicago Transit Authority,
I don't want to fucking is whatever the fuck that thing is.
They come fucking blast.
And through the door run up,
you know,
a bunch of guys with the fucking minor helmets on with the fucking Uzis from a
Steven Seagal movie.
Okay.
Don't get on a graph.
You fucking look at me.
I'll blow your fucking head off.
And the whole thing was over and he just,
his family name.
Did your pop know what you're doing?
Do they suspect he didn't suspect it until much,
much later.
Jimmy grew up in the shadow of his father,
big gym,
a giant of a man.
It was a cop,
fireman and hero to his son.
He's my best friend.
He was my backbone and pretty much everything I did
and they never said it,
but I imagine they probably took his fucking pictures down off of the high
school and all of that type of shit,
you know,
did some Oj Shit,
right?
Take all his trophies and all that fucking shit.
So it's over.
Right.
So then he's sitting in jail,
um,
and they tried to get him to flip and this is kids,
just some fucking kid from the suburbs,
right?
So I'm thinking,
well,
he's out.
He must have ratted somebody out so he doesn't rat anybody out.
He's like,
I'm not telling on anybody.
So then they're like,
I will fuck you.
So now we're not going to help us out.
We're going to fucking give you,
you know,
the full extent of the law.
We're going to prosecute you.
So they gave him 10 years,
the guy gets 10 years
and in court Bomag showed keen,
no mercy,
he was coming at you on all fours.
I wasn't me.
Oh yeah.
I mean he was,
he was a bulldog.
Jimmy was convicted and slapped with a 10 year sentence.
He's in like a minimum security cause you know,
he didn't really have any violent past or anything.
He was just getting people addicted to drugs.
That's all he was doing.
So his dad is devastated and all that shit and he goes to jail.
And uh,
meanwhile this serial killer guys out there killing these girls.
So I'm thinking,
what the fuck went?
And they keep going to commercial mean versus look and he's had to go and how
the fuck are they going to tie this fucking thing together?
The baseball kid comes with bad and six balls assembly required Neil from Ohio.
Art.
Long story short,
they ended up catching the serial killer guy.
Uh,
I forget how we fucked up,
but they ended up catching him in one of those things where you seem like
relieved and all of that type of shit.
And uh,
but he had this thing where he wouldn't admit to all of them and if he came at
him,
he would just clam up.
It wouldn't say shit.
He denied confessing the any killing,
including Jessie's and Trisha's.
What's more,
he claimed it was all a misunderstanding about disturbing dreams he had.
So he ends up going to jail for like either one to two murders for life.
He's never fucking getting out.
So meanwhile there's all these parents whose daughters were killed by this guy
and they don't know where they are and all they just wanted as the body,
they want fucking closure.
And these parents had just tortured by this fucking thing.
All right,
so they're trying to figure out,
because he won't talk to them,
you won't tell him anything.
And he's also in denial and he keeps going like,
actually I didn't kill him and blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And then one day be like,
oh I did and I blacked out.
I don't remember like the was,
he's a fucking creepy goddamn mess.
Right.
So they ended up coming up with this idea that they need a charismatic person to
talk to this,
to befriend this serial killer,
gain the guys trust.
And maybe he'll tell him where like the bodies are and that type of shit.
So they go to this fucking dude,
Captain America,
you know the football player,
the movie star looking guy who fucked his whole life up cause he got involved in
drugs.
Right.
And they approached him to go from as minimum security to go into a maximum
security prison with his murderers,
rapists,
animals,
fucking maniacs.
Right.
And um,
you know,
to go in there and they said,
if you get,
if you get this information out,
we'll take your sentence and we'll just wipe out.
The rest of it will set you free.
He'd already done like three,
four years.
And he came up with an outside the box game to get hall,
which would risk the life of that charismatic convent they had just put away for
dealing drugs.
Jimmy Kim,
what happens when I've got to deal with all these crazy killers and stuff?
You know what if I get shanked,
what if I get killed?
I mean,
am I going to survive this?
So
meanwhile,
Captain America's Dad had a series of strokes,
you know,
and was basically gonna die and he had to go see him.
I mean,
it's like a fucking movie.
So he goes,
all right,
fuck it,
I'll,
I'll do it.
We pride through the window to each other and we talked for a while and he
didn't even know about the offer that nobody know about it.
Jimmy now realize Betty had a one time only opportunity to fix the mess he'd
made for himself and get out while his dad was still alive.
But I want it in writing that you're definitely going to let me go.
So they say,
yeah.
So they go out,
right?
Egos.
They go,
here's the deal.
We don't want you to approach him for at least six months cause he's very cagey
and if she fucking,
you know,
come at the guy the wrong way,
he just fucking walls himself off and that's it.
All right,
so this kid comes walking in,
he goes in,
he goes,
fine,
cool.
And he walks in and he's like,
I don't have six months.
By Dad's going to die.
All he wanted was to get in and out with Trisha's location and as fast as
possible
within the first two months,
two,
I'm sorry,
first two hours he goes into the fucking jail
and he fucking,
uh,
on purpose accidentally bumps into the guy.
I was waiting with my tray and I look over and there he is 20,
25 feet away from me sitting there all by himself.
It felt like a magnet was compelling me to come to him.
And finally I bumped shoulders with him on purpose
and then he immediately apologized.
He goes,
Oh,
I'm sorry about that buddy.
I didn't see it standing there.
Hey,
he goes,
I'm new here.
Do you know where the library is?
And the guy tells him where the library is.
And he goes,
thanks man.
Uh,
you know,
and he said something to the effect of a,
yeah,
you're a good guy and gives him a little slap on the shoulder.
That's it.
It goes to the fucking library.
And they set it up where his fucking,
his cell was across the hall from the other guy.
And he says to him,
he goes,
hey man,
he runs into him getting,
Hey,
wait,
you stay in Blah Blah.
He goes,
oh,
hi.
It's crazy man.
You want him running across?
And he said,
it's good to be with a good guy like you,
blah,
right across from each other.
And Ego's a so then fucking the serial killer guy.
One day he goes,
hey,
you want to get lunch with me and my friends?
And at this point me adversely were fucking laughing our balls off going like
this kind of social shit happens in prison.
Okay,
y'all,
some friends of mine,
uh,
going to have some other murderers and serial killers.
We're going to get some,
uh,
maybe get some,
you know,
uh,
frapin a fucking rapper.
Something you want to come down,
just kind of hang,
I'll meet you down in the commissary.
You always think it's all just getting shanked and try not to get raped.
Right?
So he goes,
yeah,
cool.
So long story gains,
this guy's fucking confidence.
And one time he actually goes in and he sees the guy,
he's got a map with all these red dots on it and all that shit.
And as I came up from behind him,
he had all these little different statues lined up,
10 15 of them maybe.
And I couldn't tell what they were at first.
And as I got closer,
I had noticed he had a big map laid out and he dove on that map and folded that
thing up really fast and slid it off to the side of the table.
And I go,
what are these things?
Anyway,
he says,
there are these little falcons,
he's trying to get to it and blah,
blah blah.
So the guy starts opening up any finally ends up telling him this fucking
stories,
um,
of all the women that he killed and all of that shit.
And,
uh,
it's sort of kind of mentioned.
He gave him like sort of enough information about where the bodies were and the
captain America guy kind of fucked up because once he got the information he
thought he had enough information to find all the bodies and get himself out of
prison and he just couldn't,
oh wait,
I forgot the best part.
I'm sorry.
It's gonna be like a Tarantino movie.
Now we're going to jump backwards.
Another way he gained the guy's confidence was one day they was sitting in the
TV room watching TV.
He's sitting next to this guy and this big fucking giant dude just gets up and
turns the channel
without talking to anybody.
And as he turns to channel the serial killer who was unlike a meek little guy
and he just kind of went,
he just sort of said out loud to nobody was like,
Hey,
I was watching that.
That's not right.
I was watching that
like powerlessly really fucking weird psycho thing.
And the fucking captain America Dude walked up to the big dude and knocked him
out.
Just beat the guy's ass,
hit him with an upper cut fucking forearm shiver,
and just sent this guy flying through some chairs and then they stuck them in
the hall.
That's what happened.
And then when he fucking comes out,
tell me,
it doesn't sound like a fuck.
I almost don't even believe it.
So that's when he gained the guy's conference.
That's when the dude told him.
And his second,
he tells him this dude,
Captain America couldn't hold it in anymore.
And he goes to do you know what?
You're a sick fucking piece of shit,
blah,
blah.
And flipped out on him.
Then you got a little full of yourself in there.
I did that.
I thought it was good for me to unload on him and tell him what I really thought
of him and who he really was.
I said,
you know,
so I'm gonna be going home tomorrow there.
And I said,
you're a crazy killer.
And I started calling them everything you can think of.
And then the guy,
the seal killed just backed up and he goes,
he goes,
who sent you?
And he goes,
so and so sent you writing.
And he named the prosecutor and then he just fucking disappeared and the map
disappeared too.
So then it's like they didn't get the map.
So there was a thing,
we don't know where the fucking bodies still are,
blah,
blah.
But she got him to admit to these fucking murderers.
So we know that the women are at least dead.
The blobby basically in the end,
he did enough for you
got out.
Um,
and the whole time we were watching this fucking thing,
we were just going like,
this is,
this is a fucking movie.
And I guarantee you when they do the fucking movie,
they don't even need to add any mustard to it.
But I guarantee you when the movie,
he won't flip out in the end,
you know,
or free flips out.
But then he somehow,
and then that'll be the last little leg kick up.
Like,
oh no,
they didn't find the map and the movie,
he'll find the map and then the parents will actually get closure.
But in real life
do changed
going on.
It's Belper and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
uh,
August 30th,
2010.
I'll look at that.
There's 31 days in August this year.
I didn't realize that.
I thought,
uh,
all the,
all the rent and everything like that was going to be due on Tuesday,
but this year I think it's every,
every nine years.
There's 31 days in August and you can look that up to people.
That's um,
uh,
you know,
40 days has November,
April,
September.
And remember all the rest got 28,
dude,
so I don't know what you're talking about.
Isn't that how it goes?
Um,
anyways,
huck is 29th.
I'm recording this.
Tomorrow is August 30th.
And you're listening to it right now on August 30th.
All right.
What happened to the summer?
Where did it go?
It's,
it's over,
man.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Didn't I tell you guys doing joint back in May?
Did you listen to me?
You didn't,
did you?
You thought,
ah,
we got plenty of tie.
He's plenty of fucking time.
Then what happened?
Next thing,
you know,
it's August 29th,
you're looking down at your pace,
the legs go and Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
your farmer's Tan from and the fucking long he didn't do shit.
I warned you.
I told you in May it was going to fly by.
And what'd you do?
Did you spend one night roasting marshmallows as they say in Boston?
Um,
I'm doing this on the 29th,
so it will be ready early on the 30th and a also because,
uh,
this week,
as of right now,
when you're listening to this,
I will be onset.
Isn't that exciting?
This whole week I'm shooting my pilot,
uh,
for comedy central Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday.
And uh,
unless we make a horrific piece of shit,
um,
according to the deal,
it's definitely going to air.
So a,
I better make sure that,
uh,
my acting game is where it needs to be.
Um,
because we start shooting tomorrow.
I'm actually really excited about this show and as always,
I don't name names,
so,
uh,
you know,
you don't even need to know names because of,
it's going to be worth anything.
You're going to know who the fuck's in it,
but I think it's going to be great and I'm really excited about it and maybe
this will be the one that actually gets me to be on TV.
Right?
Then all of a sudden it goes to a second season and then you notice I'm getting
a little bloated.
You know,
I come to your town to do stand up and I'm just not as sharp as I used to be
when I was hungry,
when I wanted to have a show and all of a sudden you guys like,
you know he's not as fun as these used to be.
I like the old Bill Burr,
the pre t v show bill burr.
Why is he wearing a bathrobe and slippers on stage?
Is he working out of character for his new hit show or did he just roll out of
fucking bed to come down here,
drink a little scotch and collect his fucking check?
That's exactly what I'm going to be doing.
Okay.
People when I get on television,
I,
if I get my own with this TV show goes,
my standup is going to go do fucking south.
I'm telling you right now,
I never liked stand up.
It was all just a tool to get me,
I'm fucking with you.
I'm Archie already paranoid about that.
I'm already sitting there and I'm thinking in my head,
typical me,
typical east coast negative guy,
just looking for the next shoe to drop rather than being like,
oh fuck,
I can be on a hit TV show and uh,
you know,
my life could be awesome.
I'm already thinking,
Oh fuck.
What's going to happen to my stand up?
How can I work in guest spots during the week so I can stay so I can stay sharp?
You know,
I don't trust these fuckers.
Yeah,
it's a hit.
Oh,
is it?
Yeah.
I,
I'm,
I'm believing you.
You guys are fucking pulled that Charlie Brown pull the football fucking thing.
I'll Lucy,
whatever that con's name is from the paint.
It's gang,
um,
too many times,
so I'm not buying it.
I won't buy it until it goes into syndication.
What's your show about?
What is it?
Is it,
is it a comedy?
Is it a drama?
It's on comedy central.
Just you and anybody who has a Nielsen box.
Whenever the fuck it comes out,
please sit there.
Find the oldest person on your block cause God knows they have it.
Whoever is the oldest person on your block or whoever's the most into Jesus,
they,
oh gee,
they're going to be the ones who have the Nielsen box.
Those are the people that determine,
I guess,
you know why?
Cause they actually have time to write letters.
Um,
anyways,
so that's the deal.
I'm shooting a show this week that is going to air on comedy central at some
point.
And uh,
speaking of something airing on comedy central,
just to let you know,
my standup special let it go is finally airing September 18th on comedy central
and I believe it's going to be uncut.
Hopefully it'll show up late at night when my crowd is just stumbling in from
whatever fucking for the lab from the last four hours of mistakes that they made
on of night of drinking.
Okay.
And after you have it out with your significant other and she doesn't let you
sleep in the room or whatever,
he doesn't let you whatever sloppy mess you are,
just go,
you know,
sit down and you're fucking lazy boy and watch my special September 18th.
All right,
there we go.
I got all the hype out of the way and um,
I had a bunch of shit to talk about this weekend.
Um,
I know the NFL season starts on Thursday night because the NFL is basically,
I think slowly trying to be seven days a week,
which I am against.
You know,
I always thought it was really unique how it just,
it all happened on fucking Sunday and everybody was just fucking getting geared
up.
It's the anticipation leave them wanting more classic show business theory and
the NFL had it like nobody else.
And now the talk,
ah,
fuck,
let's add more games.
18 weeks schedule 18 games.
Right.
Is that what they were trying to do?
They already got the bye week so they've got an extra fucking week in there,
right.
For more advertising.
Now they're trying to add two more days now the shifts,
you got kicking it off on a fucking Thursday.
They're playing in Europe.
You know,
I really sound like a crabby old man woe your story prior on Shawnda and
everybody gathered around a TV.
Um,
I liked it better that way.
What the fuck is wrong with Sunday?
You know,
you go to church,
Yo g used and then you fucking,
you sit down,
you get drunk and you watch the football games.
Nobody gets hurt.
Show up Monday,
all hung over going,
dude,
what the fuck did they run it for?
Their Ah,
they should have passed it.
That's what I would've done.
That's what I would've done seeing as now that I know that,
that they shouldn't have fucking run it in that moment.
So anyways,
I was trying to figure out what the schedules for and um,
I ended up going on to,
uh,
see what the Patriots have.
We got the Bengals the first week with Batman and Robin,
I'm really gay anyways.
Uh,
so I was checking out the schedule and one of the stories,
if you can fucking believe this,
the story is Tom Brady,
how he can swing the Peyton manning debate in 2010 and this is what it says,
the Tom Brady,
Peyton manning debate has raged for the past decade and will probably continue
to do so until the to retire every time one seems to make their case,
the other offers a rebuttal the next year.
All right.
All of that's fair enough.
I'll even give you that.
But this is what they say,
man.
He made his case in 2009 by carrying his team to a Superbowl birth with an MVP
season.
That's what they said.
Completely ignoring the fact that the guy had the game in his fingertips.
Just like Tom Brady has four fucking super and Tom Brady has delivered four
fucking times.
Giant fans shut the fuck up.
The last time he got the ball,
he drove.
Actually he got the ball with like eight seconds left.
You're going to be cuts and call them that,
you know,
and count them on that one.
But even when we lost to the giants,
when he had time to drive down the field,
that's exactly what the fuck he did for the go ahead.
Score for the unprecedented for time,
fourth time and the biggest fucking game in professional football.
He's done it for fucking times.
He's got three rings.
Peyton manning has one fucking ring and he had the Superbowl on his fucking
fingertips.
And not only does he not drive them for four or five,
and I know I'm going through this again,
but I have to because people keep forgetting this shit he had,
he had the game winning drive right there.
The Go,
you hit,
go ahead.
Peyton.
Drive down the fucking field.
Not only does he not score that touchdown,
not only do they don't even not get a field goal,
he throws a pick fucking six to lose the game for his fucking team.
And somehow I want to know where the debate is.
Where is the debate?
Indianapolis Colts fans,
which would you rather have as a quarterback?
A guy who acts absolutely annihilates the competition in the regular season.
Okay.
And can only get you one championship or would you rather have the other guy who
wins three out of four fucking super bowls?
What would you rather have?
You won three rings.
You want one?
The debate is fucking over.
There is no debate
as far as I'm concerned.
Peyton manning is still chasing old date rape there in fucking Pittsburgh
because as much as you wouldn't want that son of a bitch around your daughter,
God damn it.
You got to want them under center.
All right.
This is bullshit that just that they just put this out here to get people all
pissed off.
Just like that mosque at Ground Zero that had me pissed for 48 fucking hours
before I found out.
It's not at ground zero.
It's fucking two three blocks up the street and it's not a mosque.
It's like a fucking wreck room.
All right.
I don't give a fuck.
You want to go in there and play Ping Pong?
It talk about Muhammad.
I don't give a shit,
but what did they save?
Right?
It's a mosque.
It's at ground zero.
They're building a bronze statue too,
is some of bin Laden.
You should've seen me frothing at the mouth like a dog that had gone.
Matt actually got into a fucking debate about it with somebody.
You know,
when out when I,
when I thought it was an actual mosque,
when I thought it was being built at ground zero,
like I was told they're building a mosque at ground zero,
you know,
so I was like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Not only did they not rebuild the towers,
not only their architects still acting like they give a fuck when the reality is
that they want the contract so they can put their fucking name on the building.
Not only is that bull bullshit been going on for what,
nine fucking years now they're going to put a mohs down there.
I was literally beside myself and uh,
I was getting into tons of arguments out here in Hollywood about it during the
48 hours when I actually thought they were building a mosque at ground zero.
Um,
and they fucking,
you know,
these Douche bags out here,
they will use to release each.
You thinking like,
I don't realize that.
Like I realize that it was not the religion.
I realized that Shit,
but you know,
you know,
how about,
how about just having a little bit of tact,
you know,
you know what I mean?
That's all I'm saying.
I know it's not the fucking religion.
Okay.
But you know,
look,
look at my religion.
Look at the Jesus freaks.
Go out there and kill fucking abortion doctors now with 18 of them flew a
fucking a,
you know,
a Cessna into an abortion clinic.
Fucking blew the God damn place up.
And then the next day they wanted to put a big brunch statue of Jesus across the
street and people,
the sons and daughters of the abortion doctors had a fucking problem with that.
I will be like,
yeah,
you know,
do we,
do we really have to put it there?
I mean,
it's not us,
right?
We didn't do it.
It's not the whole fucking religion,
but rarely all the fucking places you could put a big bronze statues of fucking
hey suits there.
Oh Gee.
Ages,
right?
We can't just fucking,
you know,
maybe go like quarter mile,
half mile up the fucking street.
That's all.
That's all I'm saying.
Right?
That was my fucking argument.
And we were going back and forth.
Then I realized that's not even a Goddamn mosque.
It's not at ground zero.
Okay.
Free blocks up the street.
The building like a lemonade stand assumption.
And as always,
I didn't really quite fucking read up on that part of it,
but um,
yeah,
so whatever.
So that's the same thing with this Tom Brady,
Peyton manning debate.
There is no fucking debate.
This is ESPN guys,
all these sports guys,
they have this nothing left to fucking debate.
So they did,
they learned that with that Yankees,
red sox keep pitting them against each other.
Even when everybody's kind of over it.
You know,
it's like once the curse of the babe was broken,
it's fucking over.
Who gives a fuck?
Yes,
we're going to play each other.
the Yankees will win it again.
Oh look,
the red sox won it again too.
It's over and they keep trying to sell it to you.
What are the greatest rivalries?
No one gives a fuck.
And by no one,
I mean I don't give a fuck anymore.
Therefore nobody gives a fuck in this Tom Brady,
Peyton manning debate,
there is no fucking debate.
Peyton manning cannot care.
He can't hold fucking Tom Brady's jockstrap.
He can't
look.
Anybody can kick the shit out of people during the fucking regular season,
but when it counts,
when it counts,
what do you do?
What do you do these stand out like a man.
I'll fucking relax like Joe Montana and drive your team down the fucking field
or do you get that little bitchy tone in your fucking voice?
Okay guys is how it's going to be on too and you get under center.
Well,
whatever you do gotta beat Marsha,
got to get close to than a quarter of an inch from.
But that one,
Greg Brady striving that fucking caprice classic or whatever the fuck they had
whipping it around the parking lot.
Making fun of how broads can't drive.
One of my favorite fucking episodes of the Brady by my two favorite episodes was
the first half of that Brady Bunch episode when Greg Brady was bringing the
fucking hammer down and it was going,
let me tell you three fucking stepsister bitches,
something.
None of you broads know how to drive.
And that includes your mother who I'm banging by the way,
who I'm banging by the way.
All right.
With their weird ass haircut,
whatever the fuck you know.
Did anybody ever have that fucking haircut?
Uh,
other than her.
I mean,
that is like,
I dunno what it was.
She took like Mo from the three stooges haircut and then she put a fucking sort
of mullet that she did a little flipped to on the back.
Anyways,
let's get back to you brands.
You don't know how to fucking drive.
That goes for you with the fucking speech impediment.
You don't know how to fucking drive Jan with you.
Awful fucking Hasidic Jew fucking curls.
I don't know what you're trying to do.
You know,
and,
and Marcia who,
I don't know why I'm not banging you some reasons I skipped over you and started
banging your mother.
Right?
None of you bitches can fucking drive.
And I'm watching this episode going to see Greg is the shit.
Greg Berry Fuck Fonzie.
You know,
with his stupid fucking,
you know,
spinning around and punching a jukebox so it plays Shaboom Shaboom I don't give
a fuck about that.
I liked Greg Brady,
you know,
for as much as Fonzie was talking shit.
He was always nice to the ladies and he,
that's,
that's seventh grade game with the woman Greg Brady.
That's,
that's how Greg ended up fucking them mom,
because he didn't give a shit.
He didn't give a fuck
Greg.
Fuck you Carol.
You're not my mother.
You know how to drive either.
Oh my God.
Took him in that fucking groovy attic day heads started blowing up twice.
Hair got all curly.
So anyways,
that episode,
he's telling these fucking broads that they don't know how to drive.
And then in the end of course,
cause they always have to cater to women.
These nerdy fucking writers,
you know,
and then the end they fucking,
Marsha goes around this stupid fucking track and they had a cone with a little
egg on it.
You guys are seeing this and she fucking,
you know,
I forget whatever Marsha chokes in the beginning and then in the end just to
fucking even it out.
So everybody's happy and they could sell tide during the commercials.
They have Greg fuckup and knock the edge off.
That's,
that's what I was trying to get to.
Wasn't that what I was trying to get to without one on so fucking long.
I can't even remember.
All I'm saying is
that the guy you want,
you don't,
it doesn't fucking matter how many yards you throw
in the regular season.
It doesn't fucking matter unless you're,
you got them on your fantasy fucking team,
whatever that means.
Evidently that makes you sit up a little bit straighter in your Ikea Office
chair on Monday.
I don't know what the fuck it means,
but at the end of the day,
how you judge a quarterback is in those fucking moments.
Okay.
All right.
And I understand the Barry Sanders out there played on the lines.
It's a horrific franchise.
I can't judge him like that.
He never had the opportunity,
so I dumped.
But when I see a guy like Peyton manning who has had the opportunities and he
has not delivered,
for them to sit there and try to act like this,
fucking debate is still going on.
It isn't.
There is no Peyton Manning,
Tom Brady debate Peyton.
Manny has to redeem.
He has to redeem himself.
You don't think the players on his team of fucking questioning him.
This is the guy,
this is the guy leading us to battle.
Who's great during bootcamp,
who's great during the war games we play during fucking regular season,
but when it really comes down to live ammunition and the fucking playoffs,
this fucking guy's curling up in a Fox hole blaming the fucking radar guy.
We had communication issues.
Fuck you.
There is no debate as far as I'm concerned.
You guys can chime in.
Go ahead.
Indianapolis.
Huh?
With the ISTEP team,
they're the fucking Baltimore Colts,
by the way.
That would been great if it and started,
I said the Baltimore Coats.
Um.
Anyways.
All right.
I enjoyed that.
I'm sure a lot of other people didn't.
A lot of people probably turn that off going.
I'm so sick of him talking about Peyton manning.
Well,
I'm going to react to everything that they write on the news and I guarantee
you're going to watch Peyton manning again this fucking year.
Just light it up.
Light it up.
Absolutely.
Five,
6,000 fucking yards.
Right?
And all he's got is that little fucking,
you know,
she's got one little Superbowl ring,
like,
like that fucking professional gambler who one time took the big pot and went
down to the gift shop.
Got himself something fucking shiny.
You know what about the other nine digits?
They got nothing sitting in naked,
losing every fucking night.
Coming home to a sparsely furnished apartment.
You know,
don't you have a flat screen TV anymore?
He still got that big fucking,
you know,
zenith color TV
that's been around since before the world series of poker.
That's,
that's,
that's where Peyton manning is right now.
All right.
Okay.
I think I fucking pretty much poured salt in the field.
Burned down the village.
All right,
that's over.
Okay.
For those of you had to sit there and endure that,
let's give you some pleasurable viewing.
Why don't you guys do yourself a favor and go over to the [inaudible]
podcast.com where you can watch all of these funny youtube videos.
Um,
here are the youtube videos for the week.
Everyone.
Um,
first one,
number one search.
This one crazy guy sings karaoke.
Um,
this is a fucking great one.
I don't know if you guys want to write a psychological breakdown to this guy.
I would really appreciate it cause I was trying to figure out this guy's energy
if,
if it's like he so fucking amped up cause he's always wanted to perform that
it's somehow manifested itself in this spastic fucking look on his face.
Tell you right now he's an Asian guy.
And the second I saw the STA fucking look on his face that he makes right before
he starts singing and when he sings the chorus,
it really reminded me a killer Khan and he wrestling fans out there.
Do you remember how killer Khan used to when he used to come on the mic,
they acted like he couldn't speak fucking English for God knows.
He probably taught at Princeton during the fucking week.
He would just sit there,
no video guys say McCall
and having this crazy fucking look at his face and then Freddie Blassie are the
fucking manage them.
The grand wizard or wrestling would step in acting like they knew how to
translate his shit.
That's who I was thinking of when you watch this guy or he really went through a
breakup cause he's singing a breakup song and he's mad at some bitch.
I'd have no,
no idea,
but it's a crazy guy.
Sings Karaoke.
Please check that out.
A youtube video number two,
Hay bailing fun.
Now if you sit in there right now writing down,
all of these are trying to remember them.
Just go to the [inaudible],
podcast.com.
We're going to have them all lined up for your nice and fucking easy.
Uh,
here's another one.
Pulled dance ruins wedding.
This one was so fucked up.
I thought it was fake,
but evidently not a,
here's another one.
Prank phone call,
a calling in sick to Walmart.
And uh,
the last one.
This is one for after you've gone to lunch.
Look up fat wrapper.
Uh,
this one.
Yeah,
You'll have your jaw on your desk looking at this one.
Um,
anyway,
so let's go back to,
this is why I always wait to the youtube videos in the end because I just
stopped riffing and I just sorta just,
you know,
and then go check this and then I go into fucking robot mode.
Um,
anyways,
let's,
let's plow ahead here.
Let's get me going again.
Let's get the funny going again on this podcast.
I'm,
oh,
I know I always trash women on this,
on this podcast and um,
you know,
so I'm always telling them the broads over there to fucking,
write some shit here,
talk some shit back.
So we can be nice so we can be fair and balanced.
Like all those,
uh,
those,
those are new shows,
those news programs that they have that gave you screaming about mosques.
Do you know,
they're making a bakery where they,
where they have the fucking biggest loser.
Um,
anyway.
All right.
Uh,
the empire strikes back is the name of this one.
Um,
this is,
this is women.
This is this one,
a female listener.
I have who just really just in a,
just an absolutely beautiful way.
Just dissects guys here.
So we're going to read this here.
A bill.
I've been listening to your podcast every week for a while now.
Um,
I like,
he start off giving me actually a really concise form of time and then you get
real vague nebulous to your podcast every week for a while.
Now,
every week since 2009,
I mean for a while,
I will see you at five minutes past some hour today.
Okay.
So be there.
I've noticed you rag on females,
but I haven't been offended.
It's funny and I know it's all in good fun.
Hey,
is a cool girl.
All right.
I heard the emails of the guys who wrote in trashing women.
So I am answering the call to write in and trash guys.
God bless you.
Uh,
let me give you a little context about who I am.
I'm an industrial seamstresses seamstress.
Can't even say it.
I am an industrial seamstress.
Does that job still exist in this country?
That's great.
Um,
who gets to listen to podcasts?
Podcasts while I work?
I'm 25 and had been married to my husband for six years together for eight.
Okay,
let's try to dissect this woman.
All right.
So she met her husband at 17,
got married at 19,
and she's an industrial seamstress.
You guys want to guess what state she's in?
Um,
do you work at the last factory that hasn't been turned into a Condo in Ohio?
This is,
this is like a character on little house on the prairie.
Does your husband have polio?
Um,
anyways,
he is also a fan of you,
your comedy.
Uh,
we have no kids,
but we do have a three year old male am staff.
I don't know what that is.
Terrier and,
and hopefully we'll have a picture of that on the MM podcast am staff,
a m s t,
a f f terrier and a nine month old Bluenose American pit bull.
God bless you.
My mother raised me on her own and I am the youngest of four kids because I grew
up without a father in my life.
I am sure that a huge part of my dislike,
that's a huge part of my disliking of men.
Is there anything better than someone who could just address the fact that they
fucking hate something and actually put a little bit of a little bit of it on
themselves?
I hope I've done that.
Why do I hate women?
Uh,
I think it's because I'm a control freak.
I think that's what it is.
And um,
I don't like people running my life or attempting to run my life.
I don't like people butting into my life.
And that's how I view women.
And it's how I view the marital laws,
which I understand were put together by men.
But I think that it was put together by the Illuminati to keep people like
myself regular guys.
Salt of the earth guys,
you know,
oh fucking just chip off the old block kind of guys.
You know the kind of guys you could pal around it say,
Geez wit Gee Whiz with,
you know,
they prevent us from becoming rich by,
let me look at tiger woods.
They cut that man and half
of the Jina came in like a fucking radial arm saw that flew off.
It's fucking hinges
and just slice that fucking once in a lifetime talent.
Right.
And fucking hap because why?
Why?
Cause he,
cause he blew out his knee because he rested on his laurels now because he got
legally bound to something that had a vagina.
That right there and as you can see,
you know what it really is?
Is I always look at worst case scenario shit.
Like look at me.
I'm,
I'm taping a show that could go on to become a hit show.
And what do I do first?
I immediately worry that my standup is going to suffer rather than being like,
hey,
this could be awesome.
All right.
Why don't,
why don't you just submit bill,
you're a fucking psycho and you're a paranoid maniac and you really don't know
what the fuck you're talking about.
All right.
Guilty as charged.
Uh,
but I do know a lot about Greg Brady.
You got to give me that.
All right,
so here we go.
Please let me share with you the reasons why some men suck.
Look at this.
She even said some men and what have you got married so long,
so young.
This girl is a catch here.
All right,
number one.
She says,
I don't like diesel guys.
You know the guys who drive,
they're extremely lifted,
tricked out diesel trucks and think that they are so fast.
I don't know what that means.
So cool.
We mean they are always trying to get me to race them in my evo.
I don't know what that is either.
And what I don't,
uh,
because they're gay.
They blow black smoke out out their exhaust and peel away.
Do you worry?
Do you live in Texas?
That just sounded like the beginning of like urban cowboy.
Anyway,
something about their huge truck makes them think they have a huge dick.
Ah,
I gotta go.
I gotta go with you on that one.
Yes.
I don't like those guys.
I don't like people who feel like because of the car that they have,
you know,
especially myself,
because I drive a hybrid.
I always get people giving me shit and then they start talking about their car.
Like they fucking invented it.
Like they built it.
It's like,
no,
no.
I'm sorry.
Somebody,
some other man had to build that for you.
Do you understand that sweetheart?
So why don't you come on,
climb behind you a little shiny toy that you don't even understand how it
fucking works.
All right,
you [inaudible] all right.
Can I kind of plow ahead here and actually stay with,
uh,
with what?
With rather than interjecting my thoughts,
let's,
let's let the females talk here.
A number two,
my mother always taught me that it is rude to stare.
I guess 50% of men either weren't taught that or they don't care.
It is super fucking annoying when men stare.
I totally understand.
Seeing an attractive person and,
and them getting your attention,
but it should end there.
There are too many guys who just keep looking.
Uh,
yeah.
I,
I'm only guilty of that when I get drunk.
Then I don't give a fuck.
I'm like,
Eh,
look at their,
their fucking titties on her.
Um,
excuse me quite down,
sweetheart.
I'm looking at you cleavage Ya.
Anyway,
she says,
get a grip fag.
Uh,
like clockwork.
If I am walking up an accident and accidentally make eye contact,
um,
this guy might look away for now,
but the second I pass him and turn around,
turn around to bust them.
Lo and behold,
he is fucking staring.
All right.
I got to tell you something.
Staring at a woman,
making her feel uncomfortable is,
is definitely not cool.
Uh,
I totally agree with you on that,
but you know,
if you fucking walk by me,
I can turn around and check out your ass.
All right.
Yes.
If you have a problem with that,
um,
I feel bad for you because one day you're going to turn around.
I Dunno.
Could be when you're 27,
it could be when you're 47.
I don't know when,
but one day you're going to turn around and low and behold,
the dude is not going to be staring.
And let me tell you something that is not a fun fucking day.
So enjoy those day.
As long as he's not running back at you,
grabbing your ass,
if he's turning around,
checking you out,
there's nothing wrong.
He's not fucking staring.
Staring is looking at when you're facing him,
that staring,
staring in your eyes,
looking at your titties,
checking out your box,
really being disrespectful,
that staring.
But when you walk by looking over your shoulder,
I mean,
that's a fucking,
you know,
it's a compliment.
If he continues to walk and turns around,
checks you out,
that's actually a compliment.
If he stops and he's got one hand in his pocket and it appears that he's doing
half the mash potato dance like that,
that is offensive.
Without a doubt.
Jesus,
where did I pull that on him?
Um,
that would be offensive,
right?
But it's around fucking staring at you.
Uh,
that means that you're an attractive woman and stop being so conty and take it
as a compliment.
All right,
I understand you walk by a construction site and they go,
Hey,
let me see your fucking panties or whatever the hell they yell,
you know,
whistling at you and all that type of shit.
I understand that.
Yeah,
I totally get that.
You know,
he treating you the same way I would be treated and when I first walked into a
prison facility holding my blanket,
I totally understand that.
But you know,
if he continues walking in the other direction,
it turns around and checks out your ass.
It's not wrong with that.
It's not wrong.
That means he liked what he saw.
That means look looking good.
That's all that that means.
He's not fucking staring.
All right.
Um,
anyway,
she goes on to say everyone notices hot girls and guys too,
but it is rude to stare.
Okay,
I'll go with you halfway on that.
You know,
when you're looking at me,
I shouldn't be staring at you fucking chest.
Oh,
your hips or yeah,
so you're fucking hoo.
Ha.
Oh,
your legs or whatever.
Um,
but on the other side,
you know,
if you're really hot and you wear something really sexy,
I mean,
guys are only so like,
I dunno,
we're only so,
we only have so much control over that.
You fucking with nature,
they're all right.
Yeah.
So I kind of blamed you in a way.
So you're right now,
somewhere in the middle of that I agreed with you.
Just take that.
You take that home with you.
I right there.
Tuts all right,
number three,
uh,
what is the nasty,
what is with the nasty bathroom habits?
Um,
I don't know if some men just don't notice or don't care that the outer rim of
their toilets are fucking disgusting.
Is it that hard to wipe off what miss the target?
A house with only single guys or a men's bar bathroom is proof that some
may have horrendous,
some men have horrendous bathroom habits.
Okay.
I'm absolutely 100% agree with you other than the public bathrooms.
There's nothing more disgusting.
The female's bathroom is actually more disgusting because you guys hover and you
can't see what the fuck you're aiming at.
All right.
I used to work in a restaurant and one of my jobs was I had to clean the fucking
bathrooms and I don't know what the fuck you guys are using all that fucking
toilet.
It's like a ticket.
It's like some of you want to fucking championship in there.
You know the Canyon I heroes like there's all ticker tape and all kinds of shit
all over the floor.
It's fucking horrific.
And you guys piss all over the place.
Uh,
you know.
Exactly.
You know what I mean?
US urinating.
At least we're looking at what were urinating you guys,
it's like a fucking trick shot and your shit faced in high heels.
Okay.
And you're hovering.
Need I say more?
All right.
But everything else that you said is,
is 100% true.
I lived with guys when a,
obviously when I was fucking single and all that type of shit and I never
understood that.
I never understood the fucking dirty dishes piled up to the ceiling or the,
or the food that you fucking ordered nine months ago and it,
and it has like disgusting mold on the side of it and thinking all that shit was
funny,
not mopping up the floor,
live in like a fucking animal slice of pizza in the cushion or however they
always try to make gut single guys,
you know,
you're like whenever they,
whenever they do in a Hollywood movie,
please,
they used to do it like back in the day,
like whenever a single guy would get up,
uh,
just to demonstrate that he needs a woman in life.
It was actually,
it was actually insulting to both sexes.
Uh,
it was basically saying that this guy needs a woman in his kitchen to start
fucking making some food or,
or something.
And it was insulting to the guy basically saying that guys that know how to take
care of themselves,
you know,
and I know that there are a lot of guys out there.
I know it's just comedy,
whatever it,
every fucking movie would always start off.
The guy would have like chocolate milk,
half a beer left and he poured on some Froot loops and then mix the whole thing
together in a blender,
suck it down and then do a spit,
take it to the sink.
And then that was the deal to show that he needs a woman in his fucking life.
But I,
I totally understand you.
It's fucking gross.
And there was nothing worse than when I would be on the road when I was younger
and I would crash at Buddy's places and you'd go to get up,
hey,
can I,
you know,
can I take a shower before I go?
They'd be like,
yeah,
right.
And you,
and they'd go to give you this fucking towel that,
you know,
they,
check their oil on,
wash their dog with and fucking,
I don't know what drove the car over it.
It felt like a fucking stiff piece of cardboard.
And then you go into this shower and it was just,
you couldn't touch anything.
Hair all over the place,
fucking disc.
I never,
never fucking understood that.
And I want to tell you,
sweetheart,
I never lived like that.
I've never fucking lived like that.
And one of my biggest fucking turnoffs ever are messy women.
There's nothing worse than a messy woman.
Cause as much as I just stuck up for guys that were not all slobs,
it's like you're supposed to teach us how not to be fucking animals,
you know,
the same way I'm supposed to,
teach you ditzy broads,
how to fucking change a light bulb,
you know,
cause you don't wanna get your nails to have your nails melted away.
Right.
You're supposed to teach me how not to,
you know,
drink milk from nine months ago.
So I'm actually the first girl I dated,
she had a bedroom where she wouldn't let me in her bedroom for like the first
three months we dated,
you know,
so I just,
we just sort of hook up out in the living room,
had to make sure her roommate wasn't home.
And I was like,
no,
honestly,
I'm,
I,
I don't,
you know,
three months.
I know you let me in.
And I,
and I went in there and,
uh,
it was a combination storage bin.
You don't look like you ever see those guys in New York City.
Like when they're selling shit illegally on the sidewalk and all of a sudden a
cop comes and they just grab it and they run like hell.
Just imagine if after they ran like hell,
they just threw it into somebody's bedroom.
That's what the fuck it looked like.
And you had to like,
it was like a hoarder.
She was like a fucking hoarder,
but her roommate didn't tolerate it.
So it was all on her God damn bedroom.
And I just immediate remember looking at this woman going like,
yeah,
this is,
you know,
we're going to live with this girl someday.
And then I continued a banger for another six months because I was young and I
was like,
but what if I never get another one
stupid.
Um,
anyway,
so let's plow ahead a number four,
trashing men.
The empire striking back here.
I absolutely hate when men honked their horn at women on the street.
I have lived.
You must be pretty hot if this,
like most of this has to do with you trying to get down the street without
getting leered at getting your butt pinched.
Uh,
what's your next one going to be?
I hate when I become a secretary in the boss thinks I'm going to blow him.
Um,
number four,
absolutely hate when men honk their horn.
It women on the street.
I have lived on my,
uh,
I lived a lot of my life in an urban setting and I have walked busy side
streets,
a shit ton.
Shit ton.
Okay.
What good does it do to honk your horn?
Like a faggy coward.
You don't,
you sound like one of those women who like throw shit when you get mad.
Like I don't know what your energy,
I don't know what the fuck it is about the way you write stuff.
Um,
you don't write stuff like typically female where it's like,
God,
it's like so stupid.
It's like,
like a fucking fag.
Um,
you do throw shit.
anyways.
Is it satisfying to them?
Do they think they are paying a compliment?
Ooh.
That capital letters really makes me feel,
capital letter is so special.
To have a dirt bag,
honk his fucking Horn beep.
Usually follow his gesture up with the bird and allowed fuck off.
Oh,
that's what you do back.
That usually makes us laugh.
I guess that what I guess that cat calls
whistles and smoochy sounds or even I guess that,
oh,
catcalls whistles and smoochy sounds are even worst.
What the fuck decade are you living in?
People still do that.
I just do not understand what the benefit of these actions are.
Um,
oh,
ah,
from my side of the street.
Um,
all right.
There's a lot more on guys out there.
Okay.
Who's getting hope?
One of them plays quarterback for the Pittsburgh Steelers and has one more ring
then fucking Peyton Manning's alright.
But I digress.
Um,
but then there's another thing,
there's a,
I know for guys to get laid,
you have to understand we have to get over the fear of approaching women and
getting rejected.
Like,
I know you guys have your level of rejection,
but like,
um,
I dunno as far other than humiliating yourself in front of a,
an audience just for every regular guy.
I would think.
Yeah.
The most humiliating thing is,
is to walk up to a female and um,
have her shut you down just because that whole bullshit of being a guy you're
just supposed to,
it's just like from day one you're supposed to know how to do it.
You supposed to,
uh,
know how to talk to women.
You supposed to,
you know,
know all about sex.
He supposed to be like worldly before you've even seen the outskirts of your
fucking town.
And uh,
you know,
I dunno now at the whole fucking emo generation,
I'm sure it's,
it's okay to now it's just say,
hey,
I don't know how to do this.
Can you give me some advice and reach out for help?
You know,
that Shit didn't exist when I was growing up.
Like they actually have reality shows about that.
Remember that guy who had that debt,
the lampshade from true romance on his fucking head.
Remember that reality show that guy was,
the guy was remember,
okay,
true romance.
When Christian Slater's,
he's going in there,
he's talking to Gary Oldman,
he's,
he's pushing that lamp shade at the end,
his fucking head.
And uh,
this,
there was a reality show on VH one teaching these
nerdy guys how to pick up women.
And that guy literally had that lampshade on his fucking head.
And as dumb as it was,
if you have the balls to wear something like that,
some woman is going to come up to you.
I'm not saying the good looking one,
but some woman is going to be intrigued with the fact that you,
so don't give a fuck what people think,
that you would actually wear that thing on your fucking head.
That she would somehow perceive it as some level of confidence,
I guess.
And that you're going to do what the fuck you want life,
which might translate to them on,
this is all speculation.
Um,
you guys can all correct me next week,
but under all that,
I don't give a fuck.
I do what the fuck I want to do.
I think females read that as in this guy is going to take what he wants in life.
This guy is not as scared little bitch.
Therefore he's going to get what he wants and if he gets what he wants,
he's going to be able to provide,
which is what I need because when he not,
when I get knocked up,
I'm out of the game.
I'm on injured,
reserved,
just sitting there,
you know,
with a swollen fucking belly.
Can you go this Sunday?
No,
no sir.
I cannot,
I cannot write who the fuck's gonna to you.
Do you realize how fucking scare of that is?
I just realized that like,
uh,
just as a,
you know,
being a guy,
like you never think about that shit as far as you know,
being able to pay your rent,
how fucking bad women have it that you,
you got to go out there and try it and not
to get a fucking loser.
Like,
really just sit there and be like going in there and trying to pick out the
person who's going to be able to have your back for not only,
I guess,
you know,
women can,
tough it out for the first two trimesters that you know.
Yeah.
My Jesus Christ.
Some of them right up until like I'm giving birth next week.
Right.
Isn't that how it goes?
Then?
They just fucking,
I don't know.
They're like hockey players just get stitched right up on the fucking bench and
they're right back in there.
Right.
I didn't mean it like that.
If you thought I meant like,
you know,
oh,
that was really disgusting.
I didn't mean it that way.
I was trying to compare it to hockey.
Oof.
Really in a pit right now.
See if I can crawl out.
Um,
yeah,
that must be in a,
uh,
like if I like walking into a bar,
I used to just,
I would walk in there and I would be thinking like a guy like,
all right,
who's the hottest girl in here?
That would actually still consider fucking me.
So it was never the best looking chicks.
That's if I could go back in time.
That was the one thing that I really don't like about myself is I,
whenever I saw the hottest girls in the bar,
I immediately just said,
add Jesus Christ.
You know,
I'll leave that to the fucking quarterbacks.
I was so conditioned in my head
to where I was in the fucking pecking order that I didn't even,
I didn't even try it.
So I went with the a,
I went after like sevens and eights.
You know,
it wasn't until I got into show business and danced around like a fucking God
damn monkey on stage.
Even then the good looking ones who came up to you are fucking crazy.
Um,
Jesus Christ,
I'm about 45 minutes in here.
She'd quit babbling,
let sa Sa actually right there.
That was one of the rare times on this podcast.
I actually tried to look at it from a female's perspective and actually gave you
props that has to be really difficult and fucking scary.
And,
um,
I think we've had plenty of stories of guys talking about nightmare chicks who
come in and take him for everything that fucking worth.
How about all these women out there with who you,
you,
you looked at a guy,
he looked like a fucking winner.
All right.
And then he just,
he just ended up being this fucking loser sitting on a goddamn couch,
playing video games,
eating donuts as you're sitting there pregnant going like,
really?
This is,
this is this guy.
This is the dude.
This is how you provide.
You know what I mean?
And if there's any females out there who have any sort of inside information on
how to read guys,
so you don't end up with that dude,
by all means,
write in and I will read the shit or at least attempt to and stutter over the
God damn words.
All right,
number five.
It's not over yet.
All right,
number five.
I do not like when some guys cannot control themselves in stare at tits and ass.
Did you already say this?
Doesn't this go under staring?
Is this an offshoot as it's like a spinoff when flow got her own show off of
Alice.
Um,
instead of respecting the women by speaking to her face while making eye contact
and just using their peripheral vision to get a good idea of her tits and ass.
You know what?
Go Fuck yourself on this one.
Why don't you put your fucking tits away,
sweetheart?
Okay.
You don't want people staring at your tits and ass.
Stop wearing those fucking hip hugging jeans with your little booty crack coming
out.
Stop wearing the shit with the cleavage.
All right?
Jesus Christ.
Why don't you just fucking walk in their top?
That's the thing I've always hated.
You know,
hello.
I'm up here.
Well,
you know what?
You're not as good looking as you tit sweetheart.
So why don't you fucking put him away and he's back.
The chauvinistic cunt is back.
All right,
let's finish reading this.
Um,
I have one friend in particular who was terrible at this.
He even will walk 20 feet out of his way to be at a good angle to see down his
shirt or window or skirt.
All right.
That guy is a pervert and a,
I got to admit I'm a pervert too.
I swear to God,
if you have a fucking skirt on that's really short and you're about ready to
walk up some stairs,
uh,
you know,
I'm going to do,
I'm going to do a little march in place that you get a good fucking 10 stairs in
front of me.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm not going to look.
I am going to look.
Where's some pants?
If you don't want it to happen,
I take the fucking elevator.
I'm looking,
I'm looking.
You know what?
You know what the thing is too.
You know what it is.
They want you to look,
oh yeah,
they want it.
I'm fucking with you.
Um,
what is going,
uh,
anyways,
what does that going to do for him?
I wonder if he has heard of the Internet.
There is way better shit on there.
There isn't sweetheart.
There's nothing better than seeing live titties.
Okay.
And you can never see enough of them.
So he's probably on the Internet too,
and whenever he can,
he's just checking out titties.
Um,
anyways,
continuing,
uh,
it is the 21st century.
You can see millions of bare tits and ass and the comfort of your home.
I don't get to distraction.
That's a classic fucking argument that if you put it in the,
in the right,
uh,
in a different situation,
you would argue the other side.
What if you were in a relationship with some guy and he's looking at tits and
ass on the Internet?
You'd be standing there like,
really?
You'd rather look at this shit that you can't really even interact with?
Then I got live titties and ass right here.
Why don't you come over here,
see,
see what I did there.
Um,
anyways,
initially I thought that I could compile a huge list trashing men,
but I've realized that as I'm growing up,
I've calmed down.
Um,
some with my auntie men attitude.
I have many male friends who I care for dearly.
Uh,
this is all nice.
I am a fan of many male comedians,
musicians and artists and no way do I hate all men.
Now,
why are you taking it all away?
I liked what you wrote.
All right.
Here's someone who just straight up fucking hates guys.
Let's read this real quick and if you bitching about it as a guide,
we fucking deserve because I got three years of podcasts,
trash and women.
Here we go.
Uh,
number one,
guys who think one good conversation means they're in.
I can't tell you how many guys I've spoken to,
a grand total of once who think that just because they made me laugh during
light conversation that I will automatically bed them.
I'm sorry.
No,
the world doesn't work like a porno said to tell you.
All right.
Wire to wire.
That's perfect.
Can't fuck with that.
Number two guys who use acts as a replacement for showering.
I hope I said that right.
I'm seriously stop it.
Yeah,
you smell good now,
but as soon as you walk away,
that second cloud of ball smells is going to be waiting after you and no girl is
dying to get with that two foot two
dudes who can't flirt.
Needin try.
Uh,
this is an actual conversation.
I had him.
What are you doing?
Me Watching Jersey shore.
You,
him wondering if you'd sub Dick.
Uh,
wondering if you suck Dick.
Wow.
And then her response was,
wow,
just,
oh my God.
All right,
number four,
learn to kiss fellas.
I know that when you practice on your hand and think you've got skills and think
you got skill,
but when you attempt to French kiss and you end up basically eating my mouth,
that's not good.
A sweetheart that works both ways.
Um,
female,
stop thinking just because you're female,
you're automatically sensual and you have a nice touch and you know how to kiss
it is a fucking skill.
Some people are born with it,
but not everybody that kissing things.
The only one I'll fuck with you on.
All right.
I believe I've told this story before,
but I want to tell it again.
All right,
I'm in this,
I'm in a bar,
right?
I'm chatting up this broad.
Okay.
She short.
For arm to something fucked up with her arms.
I can't really tell like that chick who makes the Italian food on the food
network.
If you ever really start looking at our arms,
she's cute as a button,
but there's something with their fucking arms.
She's just not a dwarf.
Um,
anyways,
so it was one of those deals.
But whoever,
she was cute though,
right?
So
aside from our Jack in the box arms,
he was fucking cute.
All right.
So I go lean in,
right?
We're going to make out or whatever.
I was fucking in there right now.
When you go to kiss somebody for those,
you don't,
not a kiss.
You pick a lip.
Either you're going high,
they're going low or vice versa.
But with this girl would do,
when I went,
hi,
she went higher.
If I went picked the lower lip,
she went lower lip.
She would basically do upper lip to upper lip,
lower lip to low,
low.
That's what she was kept trying to do.
And I got so frustrated.
At one point,
I literally grabbed two handfuls of hair.
I was a little drunk on both sides of her head and tried to,
tried to help her.
Needless to say,
after she kissed me at my Dick was just like,
all right,
dude,
you're on your own.
You're on your own.
On this one.
I don't know what you want to do,
but uh,
I'm good.
I'm going to bed now.
See you see in the morning,
you know,
I think I told that other story,
that girl doggy style,
you know,
when I move forward,
you move back.
Sounds like a rap song.
Uh,
is that a ludicrous song?
Um,
when I move forward,
you move back and then we both separate and then we come together again,
like fucking magnets.
That's how you do it.
This girl would basically,
when I went forward,
she went forward and when I went back she went back.
So we just sort of rocking together.
So I was,
uh,
I was inside the building,
but uh,
there was no friction to once again,
my dick started being like,
you know,
if this is how it's going to be,
I think,
uh,
you know,
I got work in the morning,
so once again I had to fucking grab her by the back of the neck.
Like some fucking insubordinate Hell Hound,
no,
the hand on her hip and I had to hold her still for a second as I went back.
And then I brought her to me and then say,
see that day you go,
there you go.
All right,
but I understand this woman.
You don't,
you don't kiss other women.
So there you go.
All right,
number five guys.
Who by the way,
this is fucking killer list here.
Number five,
guys who insist on a girl who's hairless.
I don't think guys realize how much work it takes for a woman to maintain silky
smooth skin all the time,
but it is a pain.
It wouldn't be so bad to keep it up if the guys did the same,
but sadly,
a lot of furry little men stick their noses up at the ideas.
Um,
how can we be forced to do it when you're Chinchilla asked?
Doesn't.
Um,
someone else made a list and was just talking about the pedophile tendency of
that.
And I could not agree more.
I think it's creepy.
100% hairless is fucking creepy.
All right.
I'd like a nice manicured lawn,
please.
That's all a mascot for.
Yeah,
that other thing.
that's just know the Calvin Klein ad,
as I call it.
Remember those creepy ads he had with the fucking people kids down in the
goddamn basement.
I'd still think that's truly one of the few times in life when I actually get
offended.
I really,
it really bothers me when,
uh,
they,
that ad campaign and when they have like 14 year old models,
you know,
sitting on a swing dress like they're 22 and they look like they just got roof
feed.
That's really,
um,
I don't get it.
I really don't get that at all.
Uh,
I don't know if it's,
cause there's a lot of gay guys in fashion and they don't realize how tripi
straight guys view that.
I don't know what,
but whoever's your,
they're really missing the mark on that.
That's just,
it's fucking unbelievably creepy.
And it actually makes me angry when I see it and I,
and I want to find the guy who came up with it and uh,
and fucking punch him in the face because it's,
it's,
it's wrong fucking road.
It's just,
you know,
and believe me,
for me to be saying something's wrong,
it has to be fucking wrong because I really don't give a shit about most things.
All right?
But yeah,
enough with the fucking sexy 14 year old who looks like she just got drugged and
can't stand up on her fucking Bambi legs.
I really,
that's fucked.
It's fucked up.
Okay.
Number six.
And lastly,
uh,
men who assume oral is always on the table.
You are boring.
A bad driver didn't pay for my movie ticket made me listen to speed metal while
we were in traffic.
But you think that you deserve to be blown.
You have dirty hair.
I can only imagine what state your Dick is in.
Oh,
that she writes.
What's that in your eye?
Oh,
it's just a sparkle that,
you know what?
That was phenomenal.
Phenomenal points.
Phenomenally written.
Um,
I'm liking this.
The empire strikes back,
the women coming back at us.
We fucking deserve it.
Uh,
let's see if I think I got it.
Okay.
Let's get to overrated.
Underrated for the week.
This podcast is getting a little old here.
56.
Uh,
overrated.
I like this one here.
This guy writes in,
he says the use of the word epic to describe everything.
And you know what's funny after I was just like,
all that's a classic.
I got to put that on the podcast.
And then I was driving down the street and there's some,
um,
new show coming out in the advertising billboard says,
something about the epic of epicness,
you know,
just classic people in the motion picture or whatever,
TV industry.
They liked it.
We keep finding the word epic on Youtube.
Let's use it in our advertising.
Um,
kind of like,
remember when they were trying to figure out grunge and they just couldn't
figure it out.
How to advertise to the,
I don't give a fuck man.
I'm going to shoot myself in the face generation,
right.
That I semi came up and I'm like,
half in grunge,
half in hair metal.
Right.
So they actually came up with that movie called feeling Minnesota.
I believe Keanu Reeves was in it.
I think it was a,
uh,
Soundgarden lyric.
Um,
I dunno what I'm anyways,
overrated.
Uh,
working in a job you hate and don't want to do anymore.
I feel like my job is slowly killing me and I need to find something else,
but I'm dragging my feet thanks to this economy.
Yeah,
Dude.
Well the great thing is you've expressed it out loud.
You've written it and now I've said it out loud.
So you'll get out of that.
Yeah.
You don't like it?
Just get out.
Get Out.
Just find something else.
Anything fucking it.
Not Anything,
but you know,
just every,
you just take another swing at the fucking tree.
Eventually a chop it down.
Uh,
and get the fuck out of there because it's your life.
All right.
Um,
what is this?
Oh,
this is some more men trashing a men with huge muscles.
I think we already,
I'm not just talking about the steroid freaks,
I'm including those guys whose necks are hidden by their overdeveloped shoulder
muscles and who's pecs could fill a C Cup Bra.
And for Christ's sake,
stop talking about your workout routines.
I don't care how many reps you did while exercising your idiot toys or how much
you can bench press.
Just mentioned the fact that the bar you use to bench press ways by itself,
40 pound.
Uh,
wait a minute,
I just lost a sentence here.
I'm so fucking dumb.
Just mentioned the fact that the bar you use to bench press ways by itself,
40 pounds,
45 pounds,
and that you added some heavy crap on,
on that heavy crap on that alone impresses me and doesn't bore me to death.
And that was actually a great point and I butchered it.
Number two,
a shaving,
I'm not talking about men's shaving,
their face is please do it because we women hate stubble.
Okay?
Honestly,
we love it.
Movies and on TV,
but the beard burn in real life is just not pleasant.
Uh,
it's not shaving,
it's not women's shaving.
Their pubic hair that is overrated.
Naked pussies are,
oh,
here's a woman.
Naked.
Pussies are another product of our culture's obsession with super thin models
and actresses and it is sick.
Think about it this way.
Keira Knightley naked.
I don't know who that is.
Naked looks more like a 10 year old boy than a 25 year old woman in ladies who
actually have sizable breasts and shave crutches.
Look like women on top of little girls on the bottom.
Yeah,
see that's just fucking gross.
This is the woman.
This trend makes me think that all men are secretly pedophiles and liked to
imagine raping children.
All right.
You know.
Okay.
I think pedophiles work.
You really took it the whole nine yards.
So she said you're pretty predictable.
Rent defending men goes here.
Now Sweetheart,
I'm not fucking defended your,
I'm,
I'm so I understand your side on that one.
Um,
I can already hear you accusing me of being a fat bitter broad.
This is how bad I am.
They're anticipating be saying this shit.
This is why I'm doing this segment because I've completely lost credibility with
the female audience here.
Uh,
she says I'm not.
I'm 26 and while my bathroom scale,
if I had one,
wouldn't would be over one 30.
Um,
I've been in a relationship for seven years and dated other people before that.
So it's not like a fluke that a guy is interested in me.
Oh yeah.
You don't need to justify yourself.
You made great points.
All right.
Underrated.
Uh,
the,
these are from me here.
I'm actually gonna contribute here so you guys don't have to work all the
fucking time.
He can kick back and you cubicles and relax.
Underrated drinking.
This is from,
this is from me.
This is from my heart to you people.
Uh,
drinking a beer on your porch or balcony.
The end of the day.
I did it the other day.
Got a little fucking balcony,
one of those one bedroom apartment balconies and I just sat out there.
It's impossible.
I don't give a fuck what is going on in your life as a man to sit on a porch
with a little breeze going at dusk,
right?
Drinking a beer with it.
It's impossible to not feel successful.
You feel like he just fucking completed the transcontinental railroad near the
guy drove in the golden spike.
Um,
all right.
here's my next one.
Underrated.
Actually using your car as a place to park your car.
Um,
I just feel it's a good sign that you're a well adjusted human being if you
actually put your car in the garage and if you have a bunch of clutter in
garbage in your fucking,
uh,
if you use your garage as storage also,
you know,
and then I think that's,
that's like the Bronx tale.
That's just the tip of the iceberg and you really just need to get out of that
fucking relationship.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
we're well over an hour.
Should I keep going?
Do you guys have something better to do?
I don't think you'd do.
I'm gonna keep going here.
Underrated,
professional courtesy.
I worked for a cell cellular provider in a call center and the sheer amount of
ignorant assholes that call me and curse at me for no reason is astounding.
Now,
what does that go back to podcast listeners?
This guy's getting cursed at because people don't listen to my podcast and they
don't realize that you don't curse at that guy after he says what he's,
what he's supposed to say.
You just tell him that's unacceptable.
I need to talk to somebody above you.
That's what you do.
This guy's getting cursed out because people just lack the ability or they
don't.
If they don't have the knowledge to just say it's unacceptable.
Um,
all right.
Number one,
underrated a sobriety.
Um,
I don't have time to read all these fucking things.
Sobriety,
I started,
I got to finish it.
See,
even the word makes,
uh,
is this underrated sobriety.
See,
even the word makes being not fucked up.
Sound boring.
Uh,
to these people.
Do people these days lack the intelligence and imagination to have fun without
being stoned or drunk off their asses?
I'd never seen the appeal in having random words come out of my mouth rubbing up
against a stranger then falling down and passing out amongst people.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't trust to walk my dog.
If your life sucks so much that you would rather be silly sitting at a dirty,
dim lit bar or smoking pot with strange people living in their parents'
basement,
then do something to change it.
Don't become numb to your life.
Rage,
rage against the routine.
And if your life isn't that bad,
why risk your health,
money and sanity on recreational poisons,
you know at that might be one of the greatest arguments I've ever had for being
sober.
It has an override.
Rided my sitting on the porch drinking a beer,
which I'm going to do right after this fucking podcast,
a number two girl geeks.
Why are men so obsessed with the size to party girls at fashion and fashion?
Niesters can we just stop here for a second?
Amen.
Aren't you?
Don't you know why I know what a fashion needs is because of my girlfriend.
She loves all of those blogs.
She goes on all of those things and she constantly bitches about those size to
fucking women and she always says that guys are into them.
You guys are the one who read vogue.
You're the ones who read cosmo.
You're the one.
They don't have those women in sports illustrated.
They don't.
And when they do the swimsuit issue,
they're not sized to.
Okay,
go fuck yourself.
They're not granted.
I don't know what a fucking size two is,
but size two,
that's that little,
uh,
those lollipop look and girls,
the big fucking heads,
you know,
they look like raggedy Ann dolls,
but you grabbed it by the neck like you were gonna.
You just run out the stuffing through the doll feet.
That's what they look like.
Um,
so yeah,
blame the people in the fashion industry.
I mean,
the,
the hacky theory is that there's a bunch of gay guys in,
uh,
in fashion and they're more attractive to two guys.
I don't know if I've just always heard that.
So they're trying to make them have no curves.
I don't know what,
but yeah,
no,
I'm not into that.
I'm not into that looking like you can barely fucking stand up.
Um,
I'll tell you what I like.
Go,
go,
look up.
Cool Hand Luke and look at the CIC wash in the fucking car.
All right,
go look up that on youtube.
We'll actually have the clip on the MM podcasts.
Look that up.
Um,
if you want to be in a relationship where you can relax and not be nagged to
dress well and go do something,
you want a girl who is more interested in surfing,
attended.
I don't know where the fuck to go with this.
I don't even know where to pick that up.
All right,
I'm done.
I'm done with the podcast.
I'm well over an hour.
Um,
and that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Lot of reading,
by the way.
That's why it was an hour and five minutes because I'm not the best reader if
you,
as you've noticed.
So that's a podcast for this week.
This week,
football season starts.
Let the shit talk and begin a patriots have the bangles next week.
My prediction is the patriots come out with a big victory.
Um,
I just think,
uh,
I don't know.
It's been real quiet up in New England.
I like it.
Rex Ryan in the jets are talking all this fucking shit and I think that it's
great.
Everybody's going to be looking at them.
I feel like the Patriots liked what the cults get every year when nobody really
focuses on them.
And everybody was looking at bill Bellacheck and who the fuck he was filming and
all the crap that was going on there.
Tom Brady's fucking knee.
Oh,
they're going to be undefeated.
It's nice that Rex Ryan,
that insecure fat fuck is running his God damn mouth with his chronic need to be
liked.
Um,
I,
I cannot wait for
week two and I just want us to fucking killed the jets to the point that Rex
Ryan just like literally snaps that lap band in his fucking stomach.
Just eating Lasagna if four in the fucking morning crying.
I knew it wasn't good enough.
That's the podcast for this week.
God bless all of you.
Have a great week.
And uh,
I'll talk to you next Monday.
I'll let you know how the pilot chute went.
Okay,
so
just stay with
us.
This will be the last thing.